J.B., you gonna get on the golf course today? Today is not a golf course day. Today is a work day, actually. Today is a work day, so no golf for you, Sean. Yeah, no, I'm going out. By the way, I got new clubs. Oh, nice. I just got them today.
J.B.，你今天要去打高尔夫吗？今天不是打高尔夫的日子。其实今天是工作日。今天是工作日，所以肖恩，你今天不能打高尔夫。对，不，我要出门。顺便说一句，我买新球杆了。哦，不错。我今天刚买的。
I just got the new, I got the same ones that you got. The beautiful tidalist irons. The tidalist, I should mention. Now, you should get yourself into some G for apparel and really You know make yourself complete. Okay. I mean I would I but I wear I got I wear the footjoy I love the foot joy. You like the G for yes, and the title is clubs the title ever to fly to a tournament How would you like to get by the way? I don't even know if we can use the cold open, but I just got a five wood. Anyway, welcome to SmartLess. SmartLess.
我刚买的新，我买了跟你一样的那套。漂亮的Titleist铁杆。应该提一下，是Titleist。现在，你应该给自己弄点G/FORE的服装，然后你知道的，让自己看起来更完美。好吧。我的意思是，我，我会的，但我穿，我有，我穿FootJoy，我超爱FootJoy。你喜欢G/FORE，是的，还有Titleist球杆，Titleist—话说回来，有一次去参加巡回赛...你怎么想...顺便说一句，我甚至不知道我们能不能用这段热场白，但我刚刚买了一支5号木。不管怎样，欢迎来到SmartLess。SmartLess。
SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. Look, you got a whole setup in your green room. I'm gonna go with the smart glass Look, they got a whole, you got a whole set up in your green room. It's nice. I know. I've got, believe me, they've, it's pretty great. It's nice. Wait a second. I'm seeing two surprise guest windows.
SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。听着，你们在化妆间里弄了一整套设备。我要选那个智能玻璃...听着，他们弄了一整，你们在化妆间里弄了一整套设备。挺不错的。我知道。相信我，它们，这真的很棒。挺不错的。等一下。我看到了两个惊喜嘉宾的窗口。
Yeah. Oh, listener. Oh, we got a double. Listener always knows before the us two other idiots. Everybody knows except me and Sean right now. We gotta have a guest. It's always everybody knows except for the two dummies that week.
耶。哦，听众。哦，我们来个双份的。听众总是比我们这两个笨蛋知道得早。除了我和肖恩，现在所有人都知道了。我们得请个嘉宾。总是一周除了这两个傻瓜之外，所有人都知道。
I feel pretty dumb today. I don't dumb. Why do you feel dumb? Yeah, why do you feel dumb? I just don't feel like I'm gonna be great at listening or talking to them. Well, Jade, do you want a couple of jokes to lighten you up? If you have new, new, okay, my favorite is still,
我今天觉得自己挺笨的。我不笨。你为什么觉得自己笨？对啊，你为什么觉得自己笨？我只是觉得我可能不太擅长听他们说话或者跟他们对话。好吧，杰德，你想听几个笑话来轻松一下吗？如果你有新，新的，好吧，我最喜欢的还是，
what did the chicken say? What did the chicken, what, on the chicken? No, what is that? Do you see guys? It's not gonna be good today. What did the chicken say, what? No, what does, see, I forget to, what does poultry say to a bowl of lettuce?
小鸡说了什么？小鸡说了，什么，在小鸡身上？不，那是什么？你们看，大家？今天状态不会好。小鸡说了什么，什么？不，说什么，你看我忘了，家禽对一碗生菜说了什么？
Or no, what does poultry call a bowl of lettuce? Right, chicken sees a salad. That's good one. I have two more, I have two more. So a skeleton walks into a bar and orders a bar. A skeleton walks into a bar and orders a beer and a mop. Yep. Okay.
或者不对，家禽把一碗生菜叫什么？对，小鸡看到了一盘沙拉。那个不错。我还有两个，我还有两个。所以，一个骷髅走进酒吧，点了一杯酒吧。一个骷髅走进酒吧，点了一杯啤酒和一把拖把。没错。好吧。
And the other one is, hey, Jason, have you heard about the new movie? Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, You get it. What happened? A skeleton walks into a bar and orders a beer and a mop. Okay. Cause when he drinks the beer, it goes, right? He doesn't have that. Yeah, that's not even funny though. Okay.
另一个是，嘿，杰森，你听说过那部新电影吗？等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等, 你懂的。发生什么事了？一个骷髅走进酒吧，点了一杯啤酒和一把拖把。好吧。因为他喝啤酒的时候，它会，对吧？他没有那个。对，不过那甚至都不好笑。好吧。
Well, that's different. All right, so here's the other one. Okay. Hey, Jason, have you heard about the new movie Constipation? No. It never came out. I don't like either one of them. I liked your, what did, wait I'm point of figure.
好吧，那不一样。好吧，那这是另一个。好吧。嘿，杰森，你听说过那部新电影《便秘》吗？没有。它从来没上映过。这两个我都不喜欢。我喜欢你的那个，什么，等等，我正在指手画脚。
This is, it's like people are joining us at rehearsal. This is, we clearly don't rehearse. I apologize already to our guests. You know what I was saying? You know what Jason, I was thinking about you the other day and it occurred to me like, you know, you see people have like fancy houses where they talk about like,
这，这就像人们在彩排时加入我们一样。这，我们显然没有彩排。我已经向我们的嘉宾道歉了。你知道我在说什么吗？你知道吗，杰森，前几天我想到了你，我突然意识到，你知道，你看到人们拥有豪宅，他们谈论诸如...
I went to this fancy place and you think about some billionaire and they have this fancy thing. And I said, yeah, you know, that's impressive. And if you feel like less than because you see them, just imagine that no matter where they went, they had to take a shit. Yeah. Yeah.
我去了这个豪华的地方，你想到某个亿万富翁，他们有这种奢华的玩意儿。我说，是的，你知道，这很让人印象深刻。如果你因为看到他们而感到自卑，只要想象一下，无论他们去哪里，他们都得拉屎。对。对。
They just took a shit there. Yeah. Yeah. That's pretty much all they do. They're beautiful mansion. And it was just them in the smallest room in that house, the door closed, looking for the fan, and they're taking his shit. Yeah, what's the name of that?
他们刚刚在那里拉了一屎。对。对。基本上他们也就干这事。他们美丽的豪宅。里面只有他们自己，呆在那房子里最小的房间里，关上门，找着排气扇，然后拉他们的屎。对，那叫什么名字？
There's a book called that, right? Everybody Poops? Everybody Poops. Yeah. Tell me that book. All right, this is going on too long. It's too insane. I feel like Regis and Kathy Lee, let's go.
有一本书就叫这个名字，对吧？《所有人都会便秘》？《每个人都大便》。对。跟我说说那本书。好吧，这扯得太久了。太荒谬了。我觉得自己像雷吉斯和凯茜·李，我们开始吧。
I know, it's true. Now listen, I do want to get to our guests because you know how I get when I get really excited about a guest. And you know how I get when we get to talk about music with guests. I get very excited. Well, these fine gentlemen are no exception. I have been a massive fan of these guys
我知道，确实如此。现在听着，我真的很想请出我们的嘉宾，因为你知道当我为一个嘉宾感到非常兴奋时我会有多狂热。而且你知道当我们和嘉宾谈论音乐时我会有多激动。我感到非常兴奋。好吧，这两位优秀的绅士也不例外。我一直是这群家伙的超级粉丝，
since their debut record. And in fact, their debut record, and in fact their debut single, which by the way, is a single that has remained in the UK, it holds the record for the longest time on the UK charts, over 300, like seven years on the UK charts. It's a song we all know and love. And then since then,
自从他们的首张唱片问世以来。事实上，他们的首张唱片，事实上他们的首秀单曲，顺便说一句，这首单曲一直在英国...它保持着在英国排行榜上停留时间最长的纪录，超过300周，就像在英国排行榜上呆了七年。这是一首我们都熟知和热爱的歌。从那以后，
they've just released Banger After Banger, incredible album after incredible album. I've seen them in concert multiple times. They're incredibly gifted, gifted, gifted, songwriters, performers, singers, drummers, everything extraordinary. Guys, it's none other than Brandon Flowers and Ronnie Venucci of The Killers.
他们不断推出神曲，一张又一张不可思议的专辑。我多次看过他们的现场演唱会。他们是非常非常有天赋的词曲作者、表演者、歌手、鼓手，一切都非同寻常。伙们，他们不是别人，正是杀手乐队（The Killers）的布兰登·弗劳尔斯（Brandon Flowers）和罗尼·韦努奇（Ronnie Vannucci）。
The Killers, the Killers. Oh, I was just talking about them the other day. Oh my God, look at that. Look at that. How cool is this? Dude, look at that. How crazy is this? How great is this?
杀手乐队，杀手乐队。哦，我前几天才刚聊到他们。哦，天哪，你看那个。你看那个。这有多酷？老兄，你看那个。这有多疯狂？这有多棒？
Hi guys. You guys look very much alive, not killers at all. Hi. How are you? You guys are very much on tour right now. Yeah, they're both in hotel rooms. Yeah, that's right. You just literally rolled out of bed.
嗨，伙计们。你们看起来生气勃勃，一点也不像杀手。嗨。你们好吗？你们现在正在巡回演出呢。对，他们都在酒店房间里。对，没错。你们俩真的是刚从床上爬起来。
I mean, we've just disrupted your, you probably have like a really good system in place and we've ruined it. We have a, I definitely have a routine that is being disturbed right now. What, where are you on the planet? We're in Austin. Okay.
我是说，我们刚刚打乱了你们的...你们可能有一套非常棒的作息规律，而我们把它给毁了。我们有，我确实有一个作息规律，现在正被打扰呢。什么，你们在地球的哪个地方？我们在奥斯汀。好吧。
Austin, Tennessee, that's a great state. JB, no, no, no, JB. Boys, we're so excited to have you on this show. I mean, I've had the good fortune of meeting you guys and talking to you a few times, which was a thrill then and it's a thrill now. And I'm such a fan. And I think the first time I saw you guys was on a sketch show.
奥斯汀，田纳西，那是个伟大的州。JB，不，不，不，JB。小伙子们，我们非常高兴能邀请你们上这个节目。我是说，我有幸见过你们几次并和你们聊过，这在当时是一件很激动的事，现在依然很激动。我是你们的超级粉丝。我想我第一次看你们演出是在一个素描喜剧节目里。
And I think it was 2006. Brandon, am I right about that? We played earlier than that. So I said the second time? Yeah, probably if it was Sam's Town was our second record we would have done, yeah. Wow, okay. So is the sound, I guess that's probably.
我想那是2006年。布兰登，我没记错吧？我们演得比那更早。所以我说是第二次？对，可能如果是《Sam's Town》，那是我们的第二张专辑，我们当时应该已经...是的。哇，好吧。所以声音，我想大概是...
But I remember meeting you. Yeah. And I think that was maybe after our third time. Wow. Was it really? Can I tell the story of what? No. At the after party.
但我记得见过你们。是的。我想那可能是在我们第三次之后吧。哇。真的是吗？我能讲讲那个故事吗？不。在会后派对上。
Yeah, please do. So they always have an after party on the sketch show and we, and Will's there. And he's got a hockey player with him and another fellow citizen of Canada. Shani probably, Brendan Shani. Yeah, yeah. And so I, what I guess quintessentially
对，请讲。所以那个素描节目总是有一个会后派对，然后我们，威尔也在那儿。他身边带着一个曲棍球运动员和另一个来自加拿大的同胞。大概是肖尼吧，布兰登·肖尼。对，对。所以我就，我想这非常典型地
what all Americans do, I say, my tour manager is from Toronto. I know you're from Toronto. Yeah, good figure. They all know each other. Yeah, so his buddy rolls his eyes and he's like, these Americans think we all know each other. I go and I grab my tour manager and he's like, these Americans think we all know each other. I go and I grab my tour manager and he's like,
体现了所有美国人会做的事，我说，我的巡回经理来自多伦多。我知道你来自多伦多。对，不出所料。他们都互相认识。对，所以他的死党翻了个白眼，然后说，这些美国人以为我们都互相认识。我去，我抓住我的巡回经理，然后他就像...这些美国人以为我们都互相认识。我去，我抓住我的巡回经理，然后他就像...
oh, what area Toronto are you from? Oh, what street are you? What street are you on? Farnham Avenue. Yes. They both lived on the same street. Wait, Brendan, I can't believe you remember Farnham Avenue. Well, our tour manager is still with us.
哦，你是多伦多哪个区的？哦，你住哪条街？你住在哪个街区？法纳姆大道。是的。他们俩住在同一条街上。等等，布兰登，我真不敢相信你还记得法纳姆大道。嗯，我们的巡回经理现在还跟我们在一起。
But he doesn't still live on Farnham. He doesn't still live on Farnham. I But he doesn't still live on Farnham. He doesn't still live on Farnham. I think his parents might still live on Farnham. My sister still lives on Farnham. I should probably. But he still lives on Farnham. Wait, wait, his parents still live on Farnham? He's still there.
但他现在不住在法纳姆了。他现在不住在法纳姆了。我...但他现在不住在法纳姆了。他现在不住在法纳姆了。我想他父母可能还住在法纳姆。我姐姐还住在法纳姆。我是不是应该...但他还住在法纳姆。等等，等等，他父母还住在法纳姆？他还住在那里。
Yeah. No, wait, my buddy Paul lives on Farnham as well. Listener has probably pulled over their car because they're so fascinated right now. They don't want to miss a minute of it. Look, that just is, you all know each other. We all know each other. And Brandon, I remember that moment too,
对。不，等等，我的哥们保罗也住在法纳姆。听众现在可能已经把车停在路边了，因为他们太着迷了。他们一分钟都不想错过。你看，这简直就是，你们都互相认识。我们都互相认识。布兰登，我也记得那个时刻，
that was so crazy. And what I'm going to propose now for you and Ronnie right now is maybe we do a special live, like just a small event concert on the street in Farnham, me introducing you guys, and we just do concert on the street in Farnham, me introducing you guys and we just do it for the people of Farnham. Just think about it, don't give me an answer now. Okay, stop the back of a truck.
太疯狂了。我现在要为你和罗尼提议的是，也许我们可以搞一个特别的现场，就像在法纳姆的大街上搞一个小型的活动演唱会，由我来介绍你们，然后我们就在法纳姆的大街上办一场演唱会，就为法纳姆的人民办。考虑一下，现在不用给我答案。好吧，在一辆卡车的后斗上。
Yeah, Ronnie, can you keep it down? So listen, I have a running for you guys. When you first performed on there, where were you in your careers and was that a pinnacle of like, oh my God, I think I made it and what did that feel like? I think it's been a steady incline of just like, sort of like, how did we get here?
对，罗尼，你能小声点吗？所以听着，我为你们准备了一个常规问题。当你们第一次在那里表演时，你们在各自的职业生涯中处于什么位置？那是不是达到了某种巅峰，比如“哦，天哪，我觉得我成功了”，那是一种什么感觉？我觉得那是一个稳步上升的过程，就好像，有点像，我们是怎么走到这一步的？
And we've just been sort of enjoying the ride ever since. I mean, the very first one, it just keeps, it just keeps, you know, something keeps happening. And we, you know, we keep busy. We know what a, what a opportunity this is. But you guys came, but your first record though, I mean, you guys came out with a bang and it's kind of been, you've had the good,
从那以后，我们就一直很享受这个旅程。我是说，最开始的那次，它一直在，一直在，你知道，总有事情发生。而且我们，你知道，我们一直很忙。我们知道这是一个多么难得的机会。但你们，但你们的第一张唱片，我是说，你们一鸣惊人，而且某种程度上，你们有幸...
I'm not gonna say good fortune because you're really talented and you guys make good music but you've luckily kind of struck a chord with people every step of the way. And that's gotta feel good because you gotta feel like we're kind of in touch with what's going on in a way. Is that something that's real?
我不会说这是好运，因为你们真的很有才华，而且你们做出了好音乐，但幸运的是，你们在每一个环节都触动了人们的心弦。这感觉一定很好，因为你会觉得我们某种程度上触碰到了时代的脉搏。这是一种真实的感觉吗？
Yeah, I mean, I think our goal has always, there's this constant evolution and you watch, we haven't, not every step that we've taken has been right, but you can see us really trying to find what the core is and what we're going to represent. And you see this evolution within each album. And I think people have just, we've been lucky enough that we've been able to take people along with us, or they've been going through that same experience. I always wonder about that with musicians, because you have probably, well, you certainly have more autonomy
是的，我是说，我觉得我们的目标一直是，这是一个不断演变的过程，你看，我们没有...我们走的每一步并非都是正确的，但你能看出我们确实在努力寻找核心是什么，我们要代表什么。你能在每张专辑中看到这种演变。我想人们只是，我们很幸运，能够带着大家一起前行，或者说他们也正在经历着同样的体验。我总是对音乐人有这种好奇，因为你们可能，
than anyone in TV or movies in that, you know, there's a script that comes before the actor does their thing or the director does their thing, or with musicians, with groups, you can do whatever you want, make the album about whatever you want, make it sound, and you gotta hope that the audience that has been with you thus far, it will be appealing to them as well.
好吧，你们绝对比电视或电影里的任何人都拥有更多的自主权，因为你知道，演员在做他们的事或者导演做他们的事之前会有一个剧本，而对于音乐人、乐队来说，你可以随心所欲，想让专辑关于什么就关于什么，想让它听起来怎样就怎样，而且你得希望一直陪伴你的听众也会觉得它很有吸引力。
So how much do you factor in what you think they want? How much do you let that affect your creative process? I'm sure some bans a little bit, and then some not at all. Where do you guys sit on that? I think we have to like it first. And anything that comes out, we have tons of cutting room floor stuff
所以你们在多大程度上把他们想要的因素考虑进去？你们在多大程度上让这一点影响你们的创作过程？我确信有些乐队多少会考虑，有些则完全不考虑。你们在这方面是怎么看的？我想我们必须先自己喜欢它。任何创作出来的东西，我们都有海量的剪辑室地板上的废弃素材，
for whatever reason, just, you know, they're lost dogs or orphans, orphan songs or ideas. But if it sounds good to you, no matter whether it's got a country vibe or an acid rock vibe or a jazz vibe, like, because you guys, I'm sure your musical taste will evolve over years, and you guys have to stay in sync with one another, but then also try to stay in sync with that other band member, which is the audience, yeah? Yeah.
不管出于什么原因，你知道，它们都是迷失的狗，或是孤儿歌曲，孤儿创意。但如果它听起来对你来说很棒，无论它带有乡村风、酸性摇滚风还是爵士风，因为你们，我确信你们的音乐品味多年来会不断演变，而且你们必须彼此保持同步，但同时也要努力与另一个乐队成员保持同步，也就是观众，对吧？对。
It's a balancing act. I think we used to just throw all sorts of songs on a single album, and we've just sort of been lucky that they've had some sort of congruent line between all of them. And now I think we're getting more into the body of work sort of idea where it has a focus. And you've created a bank with your audience that you know Even though it might sound a little bit different or a little bit more challenging to tap your toe to you
这是一个平衡的艺术。我想我们过去只是把各种各样的歌塞进一张专辑里，而我们很幸运，它们之间某种程度上有某种相通的连贯性。现在我想我们更多地开始涉猎整体作品的概念，它有一个核心焦点。你们已经在听众中建立了一种信任资本，你知道，
Don't worry about it. We got you and we've we've proved I don't think you guys ever run the risk of having a song You can't tap your toe to I will say that much and that's what you guys but I was gonna say like in JB I'll say that much. And, but you guys, but I was gonna say like, and JB, you're right that, like when you talk about there, like the other audience members, I mean, the other member of the band is the audience. Like there's some story that I heard about you guys a long time ago, and maybe you can talk about this,
即使它听起来可能有点不同，或者跟着打节拍稍微有点挑战性，别担心，我们罩着你们，而且我们已经证明了...我不认为你们会有创作出一首无法跟着打节拍的歌的风险，我只能说这么多。这就是你们，但我要说的是，JB，你说得对，当你们谈到乐队里还有其他观众成员时，我是说，乐队的另一个成员就是观众。就像我很久以前听到关于你们的一个故事，也许你们可以谈谈这个，
that when you guys were maybe writing hot fuss, like or something that you wrote a record and you threw it out, is that true? Do you talk about it as much as you're comfortable talking about that? Is that a true story? That's our most recent endeavor. Oh, it was your most recent record.
当你们可能在写《Hot Fuss》的时候，或者类似的时候，你们写了一张唱片然后把它给扔了，这是真的吗？你们愿意在自己感到舒适的范围内谈谈这个吗？这是一个真实的故事吗？那是我们最近的一次尝试。哦，那是你们最近的一张唱片。
Your most recent record you tossed in the trash. We, well, when you finished it and then just threw it out. We began down a road that was a more synth heavy road. And we realized, I just personally didn't want to make this music anymore. And Ronnie was, Ronnie didn't want to do it either. And so as opposed to the instrumental stuff. No, just as a, no, just didn't want to make,
你们最近的一张唱片，被你们扔进垃圾桶了。我们，好吧，当你完成它然后直接把它扔掉。我们开始走上一条更偏向合成器的道路。然后我们意识到，我个人不想再做这种音乐了。罗尼也是，罗尼也不想做。所以相比于那些纯器乐的东西...不，只是作为，不，只是不想做，
didn't want to fully commit to a whole like synth pop record. I would have bought that in a second. But what would be the opposite of that? You're talking to an idiot here. What would synth is? Okay, okay, so the opposite would be like maybe more a rock and roll record. Gotcha.
不想全身心投入一张纯合成器流行专辑。我一秒钟就会买账。但那的反义词是什么？你们是在和一个笨蛋说话。合成器是什么？好吧，好吧，所以反义词可能更像是一张摇滚唱片。明白了。
So, but what is that process? So like you're what, you're working on like your fourth song and you're in the studio and you're rehearsing, you're looking at each other and just go, the fuck are we doing, man? Yeah, and everybody else just like breathes like, thank God you said it, because I didn't want to say it. Well, that's gotta be horrible.
所以，那是个什么样的过程？比如说，你在做什么，你正在写第四首歌，你在录音室里，你在彩排，你们看着彼此，然后就说，我们到底在搞什么鬼，老兄？对，然后其他人都会松一口气说，谢天神你说了出来，因为我不想说。好吧，那一定很糟糕。
It's complex because there's this place in our hearts for this music. We were influenced by it, but we're getting older and we've also know what it feels like to write a great rock and roll song. And so we thought maybe that you could make a faster album maybe while you're on the road because you're dealing with computers more
这很复杂，因为我们的内心深处对这种音乐存有一席之地。我们曾受其影响，但我们正在变老，我们也知道创作一所以我们想也许你可以在巡回演出时制作一张节奏更快的专辑，因为你在巡回时更多地跟电脑打交道，
with synth music and keyboards. And then it just wasn't, we weren't getting the gratification out of it that we would get when you're writing. Yeah, because like you're right, I was in a synth pop band in college and I played the keyboard. I have to see a picture. And I have to say,
接触合成器音乐和键盘。然后结果并不是，我们从中获得的满足感，比不上你创作时的那种感觉。是的，因为就像你说得对，我上大学时在一个合成器流行乐队里，我弹键盘。我得看照片。而且我必须说，
Sean, by the way, play for these guys. If you can find it, play that song that you played us before. Just so they can. Oh yeah. Well, there's three songs. Before we end today. Yeah. Well, I'll have the, I'll Bennett and Rob dig it up. There's actually three hit songs. You guys might want to put it on.
肖恩，顺便说一句，给这些家伙露一手。如果能找到的话，把你之前弹给我们听的那首歌放一下。好让他们...哦，对。好吧，有三首歌。在我们今天结束之前。好吧，我会让...让本尼和罗布把它翻出来。其实有三首热门歌曲。你们可能想放一下。
We'll rip those off too. Yeah, you might take that back. I used to play the keyboards in this band called Sounds from the Stairs. Thanks. The keyboards. Hey, did you ever play Keytar, Sean? No, almost, though.
我们也把那些抄过来。好吧，你可能会收回这话。我以前在一个叫“楼梯之声”的乐队里弹键盘。谢谢。弹键盘。嘿，你弹过肩背键盘吗，肖恩？没有，不过差一点。
I'd love to see it. Sean, I've seen you play, and you play beautifully. Oh, that's very nice. It was so, because I saw the Netflix special and I was so, I did not know you had that in your pocket. Oh, thanks. Yeah, it's incredible. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
我很想看。肖恩，我看过你表演，你弹得真好。哦，那太好了。太棒了，因为我看了网飞特辑，我太...我不知道你还留着这一手。哦，谢谢。对，太不可思议了。对，对，对。
Classically trained. He is, he's a talent. Yeah, Jason, I sat down and played for Jason Bateman. Sean, do you wanna join our band? I knew where this is going. That's what I'm telling you. Yeah, yeah. I'll join your band.
受过古典训练。他是一个人才。对，杰森，我坐下来为杰森·贝特曼弹奏。肖恩，你想加入我们的乐队吗？我知道这要聊到哪去了。这就是我想说的。对，对。我要加入你们的乐队。
Whoa. Okay. This is, I can't believe you're getting in the killers before me. We made news. No, I can't do that's what I'm telling you. I'll join your band. Whoa, okay. This is, I can't believe you're getting in the killers before me. You made news. No, I can't do anything, but I'm still mad about it. I'm gonna turn you guys into synth pop, guys. The last thing I do.
哇。好吧。这，我简直不敢相信你比我先加入杀手乐队。我们上新闻了。不，我不能...这就是我想说的。我要加入你们的乐队。哇。好吧。这，我简直不敢相信你比我先加入杀手乐队。你们上新闻了。不，我什么也做不了，但我还是为此很生气。我要把你们变成合成器流行乐队，伙计们。这是我做的最后一件事。
You were the missing link, the record could have come out. I know what you mean though about like playing like, because I would play the keyboards and like try to really be into it. Like a drummer can really be into it naturally because right Ronnie, because you're just like, your body's moving anyway to the music. But when you play keyboards,
你就是那个缺失的环，这张唱片本可以发行了。不过我懂你的意思，关于演奏，因为我会弹键盘，并且试图真正投入其中。就像鼓手可以很自然地全身心投入一样，对吧，罗尼，因为你只是...你的身体无论如何都在随着音乐律动。但当你弹键盘时，
you kind of have to watch exactly the keys you're playing. So you can't really like move your body to rock out during the music. You just have to kind of like stay stiff and play while the craziness is happening. You know what I mean? A lot of what? A lot of neck pops.
你多少得看着你弹的琴键。所以你不能像在音乐中那样摇滚地晃动身体。你只能在疯狂发生时保持僵硬地弹奏。你知道我的意思吗？很多什么？很多摇头晃脑。
Yeah, not neck pops. Right. So I would be, I would be playing like crazy. I'd be like jumping around dancing and then when it got to my solo, I'd stop and really focus on the keyboard, the keys I was playing. And then as I was done, I'd go back into playing,
对，不是摇头晃脑。好吧。所以我会，我会疯狂地弹奏。我会像那样又蹦又跳，然后当到了我的独奏部分时，我会停下来，全神贯注于键盘，也就是我正在弹奏的琴键。然后当我弹完后，我就会回到演奏状态，
back into jumping around. But you can't do the fuck, you can't like, bang, like bang, like at the end of like all these things that I've done, we're like, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, a while ago and I kind of went with it and I guess I'm still with it because they know better than me what good music is and so I get with it. You like them despite what they're doing? Yeah, I'm in the play.
回到蹦蹦跳跳的状态。但你不能，该死的，你不能像...像在所有这些我做过的事情的结尾那样，砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰，他每晚都弹。
Despite what your ears tell you, you're gonna just listen. I love those too, but by the way. But you know, I listened to all this music that my kids listen to and it like, no one is playing guitar anymore. There's no drums anymore. There's no, and I know I sound like the old man on the lawn but do you see it starting to go back to,
尽管你的耳朵告诉你，你只需要听着就行。我也很喜欢那些，顺便说一句。但你知道，我听了我孩子们听的所有音乐，这就像，现在没有人再弹吉他了。没有鼓了。没有，我知道我听起来像个在草坪上唠叨的老头，但你看到它开始回归了吗？
I mean, I get nostalgic about a band as young as the white stripes or the black keys or these rock and roll bands. I'm not even going back to ACDC or Led Zeppelin, but like where's all, where are the instruments? We're talking to them. Yeah, I'm excited that you guys are going back to that. Well, there was a, we've only been around 20 years
我的意思是，我对像白条纹乐队（The White Stripes）、黑色键乐队（The Black Keys）或者这些摇滚乐队这样年轻的乐队感到怀旧。我甚至没有追溯到AC/DC或齐柏林飞艇（Led Zeppelin），但就像，所有的乐器都在哪里？我们在和他们交流。是的，我很高兴你们能回归到这一点。嗯，有一个，我们成立才20年
and in those, from when we started, rock radio was a different, a completely different animal. And it's, there are fewer and fewer stations and they started to, just this homogenization started to happen where they started to incorporate, all of a sudden you started hearing beats and things that were influenced by maybe more hip hop and now it's just, it's almost unrecognizable
在这些年里，从我们刚开始的时候，摇滚电台是一个完全不同的事物。而且，电台越来越少，它们开始，这种同质化现象开始出现，它们开始融入，突然之间你开始听到一些节奏，这些节奏可能更多地受到嘻哈音乐的影响，而现在它几乎已经面目全非了
as Rocket anymore. Yeah, and that's good. And Ronnie, speak to a little bit as a drummer, what's it like living in a world where so many beats are created on a computer? You know, like I would say like, here's the drummer in our band and he's standing by a MacBook.
不再像摇滚乐了。是的，这很好。罗尼，作为一个鼓手，聊聊看，生活在一个如此多节奏都是在电脑上创作的世界里是什么感觉？你知道，就像我会说，这是我们乐队的鼓手，他正站在一台MacBook旁边。
Yeah. You know? Yeah. I think there's a careful, maybe a classy balancing act, at least for me, I've seen people who are so good at their instruments, at drums, that they actually sound like they've been manipulated in a computer. Yeah. It's interesting, all the different things you can manipulate inside a computer and things,
是的。你知道吗？是的。我认为这是一种小心翼翼的、也许是很优雅的平衡，至少对我来说，我见过一些人在他们的乐器上、在鼓上非常出色，以至于他们听起来实际上就像是在电脑中被处理过的一样。是的，这很有趣，你在电脑里面可以操纵所有这些不同的东西，以及各种东西，
but I don't think it'll ever replace the blood, coursing through somebody's brain and body to produce a sound or an expression. And is that where you guys got to? Was that part of the decision where you just like, when you're saying you were an Hindu, was it literally that? You're like, we're not feeling connected to the music? Partly, you can't, there's an amazing thing that happened
但我认为没有什么能取代血液在某个人的大脑和身体中奔涌来产生声音或表达。这就是你们最终达到的状态吗？那是你们决定的一部分吗？当你们说你们是一个印度人（译者注：原文有误，指代乐队名The Killers）时，真的是那样吗？你们就好像，我们对音乐没有感觉了？部分原因，你不能，发生了一件神奇的事情
that I, that I now reflecting on our, you know, the magic moments that we've shared is me, I'm responding to the way that Ronnie plays. And part of it is how loud it is and how it's powerful and it's physical. So it forces me. Ronnie, just say sorry. Yeah.
现在回想起来，我们（你知道的）分享过的那些神奇时刻，是我在回应罗尼演奏的方式。部分原因在于它的音量有多大，它是多么有力，它是身体力行的。所以它迫使我。罗尼，赶紧道歉。是的。
If we're in a room, I gotta sing a certain way. I can't be timid. You're not gonna hear me. And so there's something about those dynamics that have helped us become what we are. Can I say something, Brandon? The beat's bigger than you. Can I get it?
如果我们在一个房间里，我必须用某种方式唱歌。我不能怯场。你不会听到我的声音。所以这些动态对我们塑造今天的样子起到了一定作用。我能说句话吗，布兰登？这个节奏比你还大。我能接上吗？
And now a word from our sponsor. Thank you to Macy's for supporting this episode of Smartless. Valentine's Day is right around the corner. Whether you're looking to buy something for someone special in your life or treat yourself, it can feel a bit overwhelming to jump back into shopping right after the holidays. Let Macy's take this dress out of searching through countless stores.
现在听一段赞助商广告。感谢梅西百货（Macy's）对本期Smartless节目的支持。情人节即将来临。无论你是想为生命中的那个特殊之人买点东西，还是犒劳一下自己，在假期刚结束时又一头扎进购物中，多少会让人觉得有点应接不暇。让梅西百货帮你在无数的店铺中省去搜索的烦恼。
Use Macy's gift finder to find the perfect gifts for everyone special in your life and don't forget you. Plus get 25% to 40% off underwear and lingerie from Calvin Klein, Gap, and more top brands. Some exclusions may apply. With such a wide variety of options, you'll find exactly what you're looking for, including a little something for yourself at a great price. Need some more inspo? Check out these great ideas I mentioned
使用梅西百货的礼品查找器，为你生命中的每一个特殊人找到完美的礼物，别忘了还有你自己。另外，购买CK（Calvin Klein）、盖璞（Gap）以及其他顶级品牌的内衣和家居服可享25%至40%的折扣。某些限制条件可能适用。有如此丰富的选择，你一定会找到你确切想要的东西，包括以超值的价格为自己挑选的一小件物品。需要更多灵感？来看看我提到的这些好主意
and more at macy's.com slash gift finder. That's macy's.com slash gift finder. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. Some of the relationships I'm most proud of are my friendships. I've had friends that I still have from high school, from grammar school, from college. It's really important for me to maintain friendships
以及更多精彩内容，请访问macy's.com slash gift finder。网址是macy's.com slash gift finder。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。我最引以为傲的一些关系是我的友谊。我有些朋友，从高中、语法学校、大学一直到现在。对我来说，在整个人生中保持友谊真的非常重要
throughout my entire life. I don't like when people are mad at me. I don't wanna be mad at people. If there's an issue, I like to talk it out. I like to keep everything clean, kind, and good. A common misconception about relationships is that they have to be easy to be right, but sometimes the best ones happen when both people put in the work to make them great.
我不喜欢别人对我有意见。我也不想对别人有意见。如果有什么问题，我喜欢开诚布公地谈一谈。我喜欢让一切都保持干净、友好和美好。关于人际关系的一个常见误解是，它们必须很容易才是对的，但有时最棒的关系恰恰是当双都付出努力使其变得美好时才会发生的。
Therapy can be a place to work through the challenges you face in all of your relationships, whether with friends, work, your significant other, or anyone. So all of my friendships, we all work hard at it, we all love each other, and if something's ever an issue, we always talk about it. And therapy helps me get to the point to be able to talk about it. So if you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional
治疗可以是一个解决你在所有关系中面临的挑战的地方，无论是与朋友、工作、你的另一半，还是任何人。所以我的所有友谊，我们都在为此共同努力，我们都深爱着彼此，如果有什么问题，我们总是会拿出来谈。而心理治疗帮我达到了能够畅所欲言的境界。所以，如果你正在考虑开始心理治疗，不妨试试BetterHelp。它完全在网上进行，旨在为你提供便利、灵活的服务，并适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，就能与持证心理治疗师匹配，并且可以随时免费更换治疗师
charge. Become your own soulmate, whether you're looking for one or not. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartless today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelp H-E-L-P dot com slash smartless. Thank you to FanDuel for supporting this episode of Smartless. The NFL regular season is wrapping up, but there's still time to get into the action with FanDuel, America's number one sports book. Right now, new customers get 150 in bonus bets, guaranteed when you place a $5 bet. That's 150 bucks in bonus bets, win or lose. The app is so easy to use, and there are so many different ways to bet,
无论你是否正在寻找灵魂伴侣，都先成为自己的灵魂伴侣。今天就访问betterhelp.com斜杠smartless，首月可享9折优惠。网址是betterhelp点com斜杠smartless，HELP。感谢FanDuel对本期Smartless节目的支持。NFL常规赛即将落下帷幕，但现在加入FanDuel（美国排名第一的体育博彩公司）的行动还为时不晚。现在，新用户只需下注5美元，即可获得150美元的奖金投注，百分之百保证。赢或输都有150美元的奖金投注。这款应用非常易于使用，有那么多不同的下注方式，
like live, same game parlays, find bets in the new Explorer tab, make a parlay in the Parlay Hub, the best way to find popular parlays, find bets in the New Explorer tab, make a parlay in the Parlay Hub, the best way to find popular parlays, and more. If I could, I would use FanDuel to bet on the win of American Idol. I'm one of those people that watch American Idol over here. I would totally bet on who's gonna win.
比如现场下注、同场连串过关，在新的“探索”标签页中寻找赔率，在“过关连串中心”（寻找热门连串过关的最佳途径）制作连串过关，在新的“探索”标签页中寻找赔率，在“过关连串中心”（寻找热门连串过关的最佳途径）制作连串过关，以及更多。如果可以的话，我会用FanDuel来押美国偶像（American Idol）谁会赢。我就是那种在这里看美国偶像的人。我绝对会押谁能赢。
I kinda know who's gonna win from the beginning, but I'd still bet. Anyway, visit fanduel.com slash smartlist and make your first bet a layup. FanDuel, official partner of the the NFL 21 plus exclusions apply. See show notes for full disclaimer. And now back to the show. It's interesting you bring that up, Brandon,
我从一开始就差不多知道谁会赢，但我还是会下注。不管怎样，请访问fanduel.com斜杠smartlist，让你的第一笔下注轻而易举。FanDuel是NFL的官方合作伙伴。21岁以上，特定条件适用。详情请参见节目说明中的完整免责声明。现在回到节目中。你提出这一点很有意思，布兰登，
because the way you guys, first of all, your arrangements on all your studio albums are amazing. And I've seen you live as well. It's just amazing. But the've seen you live as well. It's just amazing. But the mix, the way you guys do it, and it's a testament to your voice, because I know that no matter what you do in playing with how you're hearing yourself, it's really tough because, yeah, Rani, you should be sorry.
因为你们的风格，首先，你们所有录音室专辑的编曲都太棒了。而且我也看过你们的现场演出。简直棒极了。但是，也看过你们的现场演出。简直棒极了。但是混音，你们的混音方式，这证明了你的嗓音实力，因为我知道无论你在如何调整你听到的声音方面做什么，这真的很难，因为，是的，罗尼，你确实应该道歉。
You're very loud. And all the instruments in your band, the rhythm section is, you know, you really feel it. I mean, you guys come out and really in guitar and everything, and that's tough to get, to break through that, I bet. I mean, that's a skill to be able to, because you do sound very front and center,
你的声音太大了。你们乐队的所有乐器，节奏部分，你知道的，你真的能感受到。我是说，你们的吉他和其他乐器出来的时候很有冲击力，要冲破这种音浪肯定很难，我敢说。我是说，能够做到这一点是一种技巧，因为你们听起来确实非常靠前和突出，
even though the band is also very full at the same time. The mixes, I wanna compliment whoever mixes your records, but you do, it is tough to do. And again, so I saw you guys play at this concert that this guy had and you played and there were about 200 people there. And Paul McCartney was in the crowd, maybe 200 people. And Brandon, you go, you said something like, hey, we wanna sing Helter Skelter, but Sir Paul McCartney, I see you out there, and would you do us the honor of coming
尽管乐队的整体声音在同时也非常饱满。这些混音，我要赞美任何混音你们唱片的人，但这确实很难做到。再说一次，我看到你们在这家伙举办的一场音乐会上表演，你们演奏了，那里大约有200人。保罗·麦卡特尼（Paul McCartney）也在人群中，大约200人。然后布兰登，你说，你说了类似这样的话，嘿，我们想唱《Helter Skelter》，但是保罗·麦卡特尼爵士，我看到你坐在那里了，
and singing with us? And Paul McCartney got up and sang Helter Skelter with these fucking guys, and it was unbelievable. And so I came backstage, you remember, after I came back, you were in that little room, and I said, how are you feeling? You were just buzzing. And I go came backstage, you remember after I came back, you were in that little room and I said, how are you feeling? You were just buzzing. And I go, how are you feeling?
你能给我们个荣幸上来和我们一起唱吗？然后保罗·麦卡特尼就上台和这帮混蛋一起唱了《Helter Skelter》，这简直令人难以置信。然后我去了后台，你还记得吗，在我去之后，你在那个小房间里，我问，你感觉怎么样？你当时还处在极度兴奋中。然后我去去了后台，你还记得吗，在我去之后，你在那个小房间里，我问，你感觉怎么样？你当时还处在极度兴奋中。然后我问，你感觉怎么样？
You go like, I just sang Helt Your Skeleton with Paul McCartney. Yeah. That's pretty cool. Do you remember? I mean, you obviously remember that. Yeah, it was so wild, man. It was even more surreal moments was before he came up,
你当时说，我刚刚和保罗·麦卡特尼一起唱了《Helter Skelter》。是的。这太酷了。你还记得吗？我的意思是，你显然记得。是的，太疯狂了，老兄。更超现实的时刻之一是在他上台之前，
you know, you're singing and you look over and he has his cell phone out and he's filming you and it's like singing along to smile like you mean it. And I was just like, what is happening? It was one of the most wildest things. The other thing that with fans needing to tour a lot more now as a way in which to monetize
你知道的，你一边唱一边看过去，他正拿着手机在拍你，而且还跟着《Smile Like You Mean It》一起哼唱。我当时就想，这到底是怎么回事？这是最疯狂的事情之一。另一件事是，由于专辑销量很久以前就发生了变化，现在巡演是你们获取商业收入的一个巨大、巨大途径，粉丝们现在需要更多地进行巡演，
what you guys do since album sales changed a long time ago and now touring is a huge, huge monetize what you guys do, since album sales changed a long time ago and now touring is a huge, huge part of what you guys do. I would imagine that switching back to a more instrumental thing as opposed to a synthesized thing makes playing stuff live easier, more exciting for the audience since you're not just hitting a button for the drum sounds, you actually need a drummer and drum kit out there.
既然专辑销量很久以前就改变了，巡演现在成了你们收益中极大大头的一部分，我猜，回归到更多乐器演奏而不是合成器，会让现场演出变得更容易，对观众来说也更兴奋，因为你们不需要只是按一下鼓声的按钮，你们实际上需要在现场配备一个鼓手和一套架子鼓。
Yes, it just makes for a better experience if the music is not synthesized, right? Oh, yeah. I mean, we've, even songs that don't have a lot of synthy bits, we've sort of tailored for the, you know, for live. We sort of have like this dichotomy between being a live band and a, you know, doing things in the studio. And oftentimes we just sort of had tunnel vision where we're just, we forget about the live aspect sometimes. And we just go with like this experience of recording.
是的，如果音乐不是合成的，体验就会更好，对吧？哦，是的。我是说，我们，甚至那些没有太多合成器片段的歌曲，我们都为现场演出做了一些调整。我们在作为一个现场乐队和在录音室做音乐之间，某种程度上存在一种二分法。而且很多时候我们只是有点盲目，有时我们会忘记现场演出这一面。我们只专注于录音的体验。
And then we're like, okay, well, how do we dial this in for a live experience? And that could be, it's not just sounds, but it's like, it's tempo too. Oftentimes we'll speed stuff up or sometimes we'll slow stuff down. We slow it and also- Do you ever speed stuff up just to get out there sooner?
然后我们会想，好吧，我们要如何为现场体验来微调这个？这不仅是声音的问题，还有节奏的问题。很多时候我们会加快速度，或者有时我们会放慢速度。我们放慢它，还有——你有没有为了能早点收工而把速度加快？
No, I love my job. Because I just did this show on Broadway where I had played the Rhapsody and I was like, I'm fucking tired and I would just, I would play it twice as fast. I like that. Cause you guys miss Sean, he was on Broadway this year. He won a Tony, by the way, hold for applause.
不，我很热爱我的工作。因为我最近在百老汇演了这场演出，我弹了《狂想曲》（Rhapsody），当时我就想，我他妈太累了，我恨不得以双倍的速度弹完。我喜欢这样。因为你们想念肖恩（Sean），他今年在百老汇演出。顺便说一句，他赢得了一座托尼奖（Tony），大家鼓掌。
God. And we'll add, no, we'll add the applause. His was felt to NIE though. Yeah, it was different. Oh yeah, no, no, no, it wasn't the, what you think of the Tony Awards. The line. But he played, and he played every night
天哪。我们会加上，不，我们会加上掌声。不过他获得的是戏剧杰出表现奖（NIE，非托尼奖本奖）。是的，那不一样。哦，是的，不，不，不，那不是你认为的那种托尼奖。台词。但他确实演了，他每晚都演
to end the show on piano. And he's like, we talked about it, an accomplished pianist. And he had to do it every goddamn night. And yeah, Sean, you said that some nights you just jammed through it. And the cast, and the cast would be like, was that like, cause it's usually like eight eight nine minutes They're like was that four minutes? Yeah
用钢琴结束演出。他就像我们聊到的一样，是个技艺精湛的钢琴家。他每该死的晚上都得弹。没错，肖恩，你之前说有些晚上你就是硬着头皮弹过去的。乐队成员会觉得，通常得八九分钟吧？他们会问：刚才那是四分钟吗？对
I was like, yeah, I'm tired. I want to go home Yeah, what do you do when you when you yeah? What do you do when you get out there in front of thousands and thousands and thousands of people and you just not feeling it? Yeah, I mean Do you just kind of wait until you do because you got other bandmates that can maybe carry the water for a song or two? It's rare. I I don't know about Ronnie, but it's rare that I'm not excited, that the juices don't just start flowing in the butterfly.
我说，对，我累了。我想回家。对，当你面对成千上万的观众，而你感觉不对劲时，你会怎么做？对，我是说，你只是等着感觉来吗？因为你还有别的乐队成员可以分担一两首歌？这很少见。我不清楚罗尼的情况，但我很少会没有激情，很少有肾上腺素和蝴蝶效应不涌上心头的时候。
I get it, still get the butterflies before. And so it's almost up to the audience. There will be moments where you come out and you think you're just so ready and they aren't meeting your expectations. Yeah, yeah. And that's when it can be, those are the times it's a struggle,
我懂，上台前还是会心潮澎湃。所以这几乎得看观众的反应。有时候你上台时觉得状态好极了，但他们的反应却没有达到你的预期。对，对。这就是最纠结、最难熬的时候，
but I never feel like, oh, another gig. I never feel like that. Don't you, because each every audience for some takes on a collective kind of energy. And sometimes like you're saying, it's a less than energy. And don't you just get really pissed off at them and you wanna take it out on them and you can't. I'm gonna say they don't. I'm gonna answer, I bet And don't you just get really pissed off at them and wanna take it out on them and you can't.
但我从来不会觉得“哦，又是场演出”。我从不这么觉得。难道不会吗？因为对某些人来说，每场观众都会产生一种集体的能量。有时就像你说的，那是一种不足的能量。难道你不会对他们真的很生气，很想把气撒在他们身上却又不能这么做吗？我要说他们不会。我要回答，我敢打赌难道你不会对他们真的很生气，很想把气撒在他们身上却又不能这么做吗？
I'm gonna say they don't. I'm gonna answer, I bet they don't. No, yeah, we can't take it out on them. We gotta be professional. All right. When's the last time you guys, do you guys see a lot of live music yourself? Do you guys go to concerts and kind of experience
我要说他们不会。我要回答，我敢打赌他们不会。不，对，我们不能把气撒在他们身上。我们得保持专业。好吧。你们上一次是什么时候，你们自己会看很多现场音乐吗？你们会去听演唱会，去体验
what it's like as an audience too and kind of let that inform your performances. Oh yeah. Yeah. And you know, especially on tour, if we're touring with somebody, it's always helpful to get out there and just, you know, it helps get the blood moving a little bit.
作为观众的感觉，并以此来丰富你们的表演吗？哦，会啊。对。而且你知道的，特别是巡演的时候，如果我们和某人一起巡演，出去走走总是很有帮助的，你知道的，这能让血液稍微循环起来。
Oh, we're gonna be doing that in an hour. In an hour? Yeah, well, yeah. No, I mean, you know, watching somebody before you play or something. Who do you guys touring with right now? Like who in the last year? I don't wanna put you on the spot, we can always.
哦，我们一个小时后就要这么做了。一个小时后？对，好吧，对。不，我的意思是，你知道的，在你们上台前看别人演出什么的。你们现在正和谁一起巡演？比如过去一年里有谁？我不想把你们架在火上烤，我们可以随时。
It's okay. Yeah, no, we did a ton of shows with Johnny Marr from the school. Oh yeah. Love. Oh my God, I love Johnny Marr. Love Johnny Marr of the Smith, JB. So you don't get to play.
没关系。对，不，我们和The Smiths的强尼·马尔一起做过很多场演出。哦，对。太喜欢了。天哪，我太喜欢强尼·马尔了。喜欢The Smiths的强尼·马尔，JB。所以你没法弹。
Get your hand off the pearls. Well, yeah. One. Love Johnny Marr of the Smiths, JB. So, you know what? Get your hand off the pearls, Will. One of the great, one of the top three guitarists. One of the top three guitarists of all time. One of the top three guitarists of all time. Oh yeah. Do you like the Smiths? I love the Smiths. Yeah, no, you know what we did?
冷静点，威廉。好吧，对。一。喜欢The Smiths的强尼·马尔，JB。所以，你知道吗？冷静点，威尔。史上最伟大、前三名的吉他手之一。史上前三的吉他手之一。史上前三的吉他手之一。哦，对。你喜欢The Smiths吗？我超爱The Smiths。对，不，你知道我们做了什么吗？
We did a Smiths, one or two Smith songs we would do every night with them. Yes. No way. What songs? I just saw you, I just saw a video of you guys. Shut up. Shut up, Sean. What songs did you guys do?
我们做了一首The Smiths的歌，每晚都会和他们一起合唱一两首The Smiths的歌。真的吗？什么歌？我刚看到你，我刚刚看到你们的一个视频。闭嘴。闭嘴，肖恩。你们唱了什么歌？
We did this charming man with him is how we first... I love it. Sean? And then we did, we did, please, please, please let me get what I want. I want to get the greatest. It's the greatest. Listen, this one, how deep do you go with the Smiths? I go very.
我们和他合唱了《This Charming Man》，这就是我们最初……太棒了。肖恩？然后我们还唱了，我们唱了《Please, Please, Please Let Me Get What I Want》。这首歌太棒了。这是最棒的。听着，这个，你对The Smiths的歌了解有多深？我了解得很深。
We did what she said. Oh my god. Yes, I know what she said. You almost put two hands on your pearls just then. Like fully punk rock Smith's what she said. We did Stop Me if you think you've heard this one before. Oh, Stop Me. Oh, Stop Me. You know, it's wild.
我们唱了《What She Said》。天哪。对，我知道《What She Said》。你刚才差点把两只手都放在珍珠项链上了。就像是完全朋克摇滚版的The Smiths的《What She Said》。我们还唱了《Stop Me If You Think You've Heard This One Before》。哦，《Stop Me》。哦，《Stop Me》。你知道，这太疯狂了。
They broke up before they toured that. That's on the last album. Is that, hang on, is that not louder than bombs? Is that? No, Stop Me is on Strange W me's on is on strange ways here I'm strange ways here we come yeah, so so we're up there and we're about to play it and he tells me you know I've never I've never played this with a singer No way so I was I was like this is so
他们在那张专辑巡演前就解散了。那是最后一张专辑里的。那是，等等，那不是《Louder Than Bombs》里的吗？那是？不，《Stop Me》在《Strange Ways Here We Come》里，在《Strange Ways Here We Come》里，对，所以，所以我们站在台上，正准备演奏，他告诉我，你知道吗，我从来没和主唱一起演奏过这首歌。真的吗？所以我当时觉得这太
Amazing weird. Yeah, you're up there singing stop me with him And it's the first time he's done it because it was meant to be with Morrissey. That's weird. Yeah, you're up there singing, stop me with him. And it's the first time he's done it because it was meant to be with Morrissey. That's crazy. Were they a big, who are your big influences? I've always wanted to know because you guys have definitely the Smiths. Yeah.
神奇又诡异了。对，你站在台上和他一起唱《Stop Me》。这是他第一次这么做，因为这首歌本来是和莫里西一起唱的。这太诡异了。对，你站在台上和他一起唱《Stop Me》。这是他第一次这么做，因为这首歌本来是和莫里西一起唱的。这太疯狂了。他们是一个很大的，谁是你们最大的影响？我一直想知道，因为你们绝对有The Smiths的影子。对。
Yeah. That's so cool. I can hear it now that you say that. I guess I can hear some of it. We were just last night, we were singing some early Depeche Mode. Oh, here they come. Get me started. We were just, last night we were seeing some early Depeche Mode. Oh, here they come. Get me started.
对。太酷了。你这么一说我听出来了。我想我能听出一些。我们昨晚还在唱一些早期的Depeche Mode。哦，他们来了。让我开始吧。我们昨晚还在唱一些早期的Depeche Mode。哦，他们来了。让我开始吧。
Yeah, so that Brandon and I sort of, we melt. We like that band. Yeah, they're incredible. They're incredible. No, there's not a lot of stuff. What other bands? I wanna hear what other bands. I just wanna hear what other bands they liked.
对，所以布兰登和我某种程度上，我们融为一体了。我们喜欢那个乐队。对，他们太不可思议了。太不可思议了。不，没有多少东西。还有什么乐队？我想听听还有什么乐队。我只是想听听他们还喜欢什么乐队。
Okay. Going up. It was New Order and the Smiths and the cars. Guys, I mean, it's like we're family. You guys can stay here. Sean, go change. You're saying everything I love. Did you guys get it?
好吧。接招。有New Order、The Smiths还有The Cars。伙计们，我的意思是，感觉我们就像一家人。你们可以留在这里。肖恩，去换身衣服。你说的全是我爱听的。你们明白了吗？
Were you guys influenced at all by any sort of like 90s indie bands too? Yeah. Yeah, Ronnie's, I'm a little bit younger. And so when that stuff was happening, I was just, a lot of it was a little bit heavy for me. So my brother was older than me and he had passed on this other stuff to me. But I think Ronnie was definitely.
你们受过90年代任何独立乐队的影响吗？对。对，罗尼的，我稍微年轻一点。所以当那些事情发生的时候，我只是，其中很多对当时的我觉得有点沉重。所以我的哥哥比我大，他把这些其他的东西传给了我。但我认为罗尼绝对是。
Ronnie, what were you? Echo and the Bunny men, Susie and the Bunchies. Well, that's earlier, but yes for sure. Oh yeah, that's the 90s. But Ronnie, were you like, I'm like a pavement built to spill guy. Like. Sure. Yeah.
罗尼，你呢？Echo and the Bunnymen，Siouxsie and the Banshees。好吧，那是更早的，但确实是的。哦，对，那是90年代的。但罗尼，你会不会觉得，我更像是个Pavement和Guided by Voices迷。就像。当然。对。
All these guys, Dyson for Jr. Sebadio. Oh my God. You know, all these guys. Oasis came around for me. Oasis. Yeah. Yeah. 90s.
所有这些家伙，Dinosaur Jr.，Sebadoh。天哪。你知道，所有这些家伙。Oasis后来对我也产生了影响。Oasis。对。对。90年代。
Did it take a minute? Did Oasis take a minute for you, Brendan? Or you right into it? It took me a minute and then I sort of became obsessed. I would consider an Oasis tattoo when I was a little... Did you really? Did you really? I'm so thankful I didn't do that.
花了一点时间吗？Oasis花了一点时间才吸引到你吗，布兰登？还是你一下子就迷上了？花了我一会儿时间，然后我差不多就着迷了。我小的时候甚至考虑过纹一个Oasis的纹身……真的吗？真的吗？我很庆幸我当时没那么做。
I mean, instead you went with soft sell, I heard, right? Just on the smaller back. Soft sell. I had the same thing with Oasis, where I was like, at first I was like, I don't know and then became obsessed with them too. They were so, so rad. Sorry, Jason, I cut you off 50 times
我是说，相反你纹了Soft Cell的标志，我听说，对吧？就在后腰上。Soft Cell。我对Oasis也有过同样的感受，起初我觉得，我不知道，然后我也开始迷上他们。他们太棒了，太酷了。抱歉，杰森，我打断了你50次，
because I'm geeking out with this. No, it's Sean. Go ahead, Sean. Oh, I have a thousand questions if I may. Yeah, sure, go ahead. First of all, we talk about live shows. I always ask whenever musicians come on, what's your best, worst live show experience story? Like the thing that went wrong the most.
因为我跟他们聊得太入迷了。不，是肖恩。继续吧，肖恩。哦，如果可以的话，我有上千个问题。对，当然，请继续。首先，我们聊到了现场演出。每当音乐家来做客时，我总是会问，你们经历过的最好、最糟糕的现场演出故事是什么？就是最容易出岔子的那种。
Well, there is the opposite situation where there were two things that really happened at this. We did a stadium run last year in the UK and we were in Manchester and two things happened. Another, a girl made a sign to wanting to play drums on one of our songs and we brought her up. And when I was back there, I was like, you know the song, just kind of watch me
好吧，也有相反的情况，当时在这场演出中确实发生了两件事。我们去年在英国进行体育场巡演时，我们在曼彻斯特，发生了两件事。另外，有个女孩举了个牌子，说想在我们的歌里打鼓，我们就把她请了上台。当我在后面的时候，我说，你知道这首歌，就看着我点，
because I jump on guitar for a second. And she told us that she wanted to do something brave because her best friend, she's like 16 years old maybe, her best friend's going through cancer and that's a brave thing for her to go through. And she said she wanted to do something brave. So I learned this song, I said, get on up there. And she was excellent.
因为我要去弹一会儿吉他。她告诉我们，她想做一件勇敢的事，因为她的好朋友——她大概16岁吧——她的好朋友正在患癌症，对她来说经历这些已经很勇敢了。她说她想做一件勇敢的事。所以我学会了这首歌，我说，上去吧。她表现得非常出色。
I mean, she totally knocked it out of the park. And it was one of the best gigs maybe of the year. It was like this huge soccer stadium. Wow. How long ago? And we actually, this was last year, last spring. Yeah. Is that one of us?
我的意思是，她彻底惊艳全场。这可能是今年最好的演出之一。那是一个巨大的足球场。哇。多久以前的事？我们实际上，这是去年，去年春天。对。那是我们中的一个吗？
But the other thing that happened was, and Brandon stopped the show, he sees this guy crowd surfing from the front of house, which is where the sound board, the mixing board, our sound guy lives. He's like 80 years old. He's, as he gets closer, you see that there's, there's his old fella just riding the wave.
但发生的另一件事是，布兰登叫停了演出，他看到一个家伙从前场人群中进行人体冲浪，前场就是调音台、混音台所在的地方，我们的调音师在那里。他大概80岁了。当他靠近时，你发现，那是一个老头在乘风破浪。
And he, he, Well, what the fuck? They dropped him. They dropped him. He drops. Brandon stops the show. This is real on his hit. On his hit. Brandon stops the show because it looks like you just saw feet and then just... and then you didn't see the guy anymore. So we stopped.
然后他，他，搞什么鬼？他们把他摔了。他们把他摔了。他摔下去了。布兰登叫停了演出。这是真的，就在他的热门歌曲上。就在他的热门歌声中。布兰登叫停了演出，因为看起来你只看到了脚，然后就……然后就再也看不到那个人了。所以我们停了下来。
Brandon checked on him to see if he was okay. And he popped up in a fit of joy. And he hugged me. I went down and hugged him. What did he say to you? You asked, Hey, are you all right? I go, what are you doing? You know?
布兰登过去查看他是否还好。他突然从狂喜中坐了起来。他还拥抱了我。我走下去抱了他。他对你说了什么？你问，嘿，你还好吗？我说，你在干嘛呢？你知道吗？
And he said, I'm enjoying myself. The next day, the next day in the papers, all the headlines read crowd surfing pensioner. That's hysterical. I love if that would become like a thing at killer's concert that like old old dudes would just crowd surf like that becomes something that happens. I once did some stage diving in Vancouver.
他说，我玩得很开心。第二天，报纸的头条全写着“冲浪老大爷”。这太搞笑啦。如果这能成为The Killers演唱会上的一种特色，让那些老头子们也这样人体冲浪，那就太棒了。我以前在温哥华玩过舞台跳水。
You did some? I did some, yeah. In Vancouver? Yeah, the stage is only a couple of feet tall, but I actually had to jump up to get onto the people's hands. And was Andrew Ridgely scared? Did he see you?
你玩过？我玩过，对。在温哥华？对，舞台只有几英尺高，但我实际上得跳起来才能抓到大家的手。安德鲁·里杰利害怕吗？他看到你了吗？
It was a huge wham. Oh, listen, they get me fired up. They get me fired up. Sorry, Sean, you were gonna say? Pretty weird in your short shorts. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well, what was left of them? Please go ahead, Sean. You fell out of the cage you were dancing in all this.
那是一场巨大的WHAM。哦，听着，他们把我点燃了。他们把我点燃了。抱歉，肖恩，你刚才想说什么？你穿着超短裤看起来怪怪的。对，对，对。好吧，还剩下多少。请继续，肖恩。你从你跳舞的笼子里掉出来了，所有这些。
Yeah, they left it unlocked. It wasn't smart. Sean, you were saying? Yeah, yeah. Killed Sean. Look at him. All right, so, well, guys, I have a question. Who did that, Sean? To that point, I was, and I used to work in the entertainment committee in college and we would get, I was in tours like seven people. Coming out of the shocker department.
对，他们忘了锁门。这可不明智。肖恩，你刚才在说？对，对。干掉肖恩。看看他。好吧，那么，伙计们，我有个问题。谁干的，肖恩？说到这个，我以前，我曾在大学的文娱委员会工作过，我们会接待，我带过那种七个人的巡演团。从神经病科出来的。
What? What nerdy shit did you not do? Let's just get to that. God damn. President of the entertainment committee, Sean Hayes calling. No, I was in the entertainment committee in college and there was like seven of us
什么？你没干过什么书呆子气的事？我们直接说这个吧。真他妈的。文娱委员会主席肖恩·海斯驾到。不，我上大学时在文娱委员会，当时大概有七个人，
and we were in charge of which bands? Stop fucking saying that. Yeah, we're past it. Which bands were coming to the college, Illinois State University, one of the best universities in the world. And we got like the B52s. And I remember NXS came and people were like, what's inks? Like they didn't know the name.
我们负责邀请哪些乐队？别他妈说了。行了，我们跳过这个。哪些乐队会来我们学校，伊利诺伊州立大学，世界上最好的大学之一。我们请来了B-52s乐队。我还记得INXS来的时候，人们问，什么叫Inks？他们甚至不知道这个名字。
And then it was like, and who else? Red Hot Chili Peppers, like all these people. And it was Pearl Jam and Pearl Jam was playing and people were stage diving and like body surfing. And I'm work, I'm maybe 70 pounds. And I'm supposed to block the crowd from getting to the stage. And I saw them coming and I just would run.
然后还有，还有谁？Red Hot Chili Peppers，诸如此类的人。还有Pearl Jam，Pearl Jam在演出，人们在舞台跳水和人体冲浪。而我当时在工作，我可能只有70磅重。我的任务是阻止观众冲上舞台。我看到他们冲过来时，我只会逃跑。
I was like, I was the worst. I'm entertainment committee, not security committee. Yeah, I had my little badge on. Hold it. Oh, did you know about that? Okay, so anyway, my question is, how do you guys meet? Yeah. Yeah.
我当时就像，我是最差的。我是娱乐委员会的，不是安全委员会的。是的，我带着我的小徽章。等等。哦，你知道这回事吗？好吧，无论如何，我的问题是，你们是怎么认识的？是的。是的。
He's the best. He's the best guys, is he not? Award winning interviewer, Sean. By the way, Ronnie and Brandon, you guys probably don't know this. Sean was once nominated for- Best host. For best host of a podcast.
他是最棒的。他是个顶尖人物，对吧？屡获殊荣的采访者，肖恩。顺便说一句，罗尼和布兰登，你们可能不知道这一点。肖恩曾获得过提名——最佳主持人。为一个播客的最佳主持人。
On a podcast that's co-hosted by, it's three people. They singled him out and wanted to give him a singular award because his questions are so damn good. Because of questions like that. How'd you meet? How'd you meet? And then what's a funny story that happened live? Hey, but we all enjoy the best stories.
在一个由三个人共同主持的播客中。他们单单挑出了他，想要授予他一个个人奖项，因为他的提问实在是太棒了。正是因为像这样的问题。你们是怎么认识的？你们是怎么认识的？然后，在现场发生过什么有趣的故事吗？嘿，不过我们都很享受最棒的故事。
You're right. How did you meet? We actually met like in a, we got to go fast because it looked like a business meeting. Me and our guitar player met through the classified ads in Las Vegas. No way. Is that true? Yeah. So probably the last band to form that way.
你说得对。你们是怎么认识的？其实我们是在一个，得快点说，因为听起来像商务会议。我和我们的吉他手是通过拉斯维加斯的分类广告认识的。不会吧？真的吗？对啊。所以这可能是最后一支用这种方式组建的乐队了。
Wow. You and Scotty met some at the back of the paper. Was it? Yeah, Craig's List. Yeah. You met in the class of Fides and then we didn't have, we had a different drummer and a different bass player for a while who they were not into it.
哇。你和斯科特是在报纸背面登的广告认识的？是吗？对，Craigslist。对。你们通过分类广告认识的，然后我们有一段时间用过不同的鼓手和不同的贝斯手，但他们都不太投入。
They weren't at the right fit. Yeah, they were at the right fit. Sure. And one night we were playing and opening, were we opening for, what was her name? Oh, Anne's band. Oh, Anne Murray. And Ronnie was filling in for this girl.
他们不是最合适的人选。对，他们不是最合适的人选。确实。有一天我们在演出，暖场，我们是在给谁暖场？叫什么名字来着？哦，安的乐队。哦，安·默里。罗尼当时在替这个女孩代班。
And he happened to see us and he just, Ronnie has a way of just cutting right to the chase and he just said, you know, you guys would be good if you had a real drummer or something like that. I love that. The rhythm section needed help. A rhythm section.
他刚好看到我们，罗尼就是那种有什么说什么的人，他直接就说，你知道吗，你们要是找个真正的鼓手什么的，其实还挺不错的。我喜欢这样。节奏部需要帮忙。节奏部。
And so we, I mean, instantly just before we knew what we were in his garage and then we had to. It wasn't for, I wasn't trying to like shoehorn my way in. I actually, I recommended a couple drummers that just again weren't the right fit. Like much better drummers in my cells. But did you recommend them knowing that they were not gonna be the right fit so that they would have to go
所以我们，我的意思是，几乎瞬间，在我们反应过来之前，我们就已经在他的车库里了，然后我们不得不。其实不是为了，我当时并不是想硬挤进去。我其实推荐了几个鼓手，但同样地，他们也不是最合适的人选。比我自己好得多的鼓手。但你推荐他们的时候，是不是就知道他们不合适，这样他们就只能
to you Ronnie Bios? No, I was like, I was on this trajectory as like, I must finish school so I don't end up homeless. Right. And I was just doing that, but the songs they had, even at the time, even songs we don't even play anymore were just like calling me. It was just, I was familiar with it already.
去找你罗尼·巴乌斯了？不，我当时的想法是，我必须完成学业，这样才不会流落街头。对。我当时就在做这个，但是他们当时的那些歌，甚至是一些我们现在都不常演的歌，都在召唤我。我已经对它们很熟悉了。
I was just, you know, I knew where they were coming from. And I think that was part of the problem with the other rhythm section is like the other two guys had no idea where Dave and Brandon were going or headed and they were just kind of just going through the motions. So then the first time that you guys played as a band, when you were like kind of doing the like looking around going like, all right. Yeah.
我只是，你知道，我知道他们的灵感从何而来。我想这也是另一个节奏部的问题所在，另外两个人根本不知道戴夫和布兰登要去哪里或走向何方，他们只是在按部就班地走过场。所以，当你们第一次以乐队的形式一起演奏时，当你们那种环顾四周，心想“好吧”的时候。对。
Well, we were like, you know, let's try it out. Like, let's see what happens. And we just ended up like playing hours and making songs. Really? And the first day, just playing. And then we got really, really. By the way, we should know, Jason's laughing because he knows I've done this bit for you.
嗯，我们当时想，你知道的，试试看吧。看看会发生什么。结果我们最后弹了好几个小时，创作了歌曲。真的吗？第一天，就在那儿弹。然后我们变得真的，真的。顺便说一句，我们得说明一下，杰森在笑，因为他知道我为你排练过这个梗。
It's so stupid. Which is my impression of every bassist, right? Which is when he makes, when the singer makes eye contact with him. The bass gets so happy. So he every bassist, right? Which is when he makes, when the singer makes eye contact with him. So he's just on his own like this, right? So he's like this, so he's just like this, plain face. And the singer looks at him and goes, and he goes, yeah.
太蠢了。也就是我对所有贝斯手的印象，对吧？也就是当他做出，当主唱和贝斯手有眼神接触的时候。贝斯手就会变得超级开心。所以他，每个贝斯手，对吧？就是当主唱和他有眼神接触的时候。所以他就像这样一个人待着，对吧？所以他就像这样，面无表情。然后主唱看着他，然后他“耶”。
Yeah, that's when the knees stay together and he goes into a deep squat. Super happy. I see it. Oh boy. He's so stoked. And we will be right back. We get support from Tropical Smoothie Cafe.
对，就是这个时候膝盖并拢，然后做一个深深的下蹲。超级开心。我看到了。哦天哪。他太兴奋了。我们马上回来。我们得到了Tropical Smoothie Cafe的大力支持。
Tropical Smoothie Cafe believes you deserve a getaway every day, not just once a year. They're introducing four new Tropic bowls to their lineup of delicious tropical smoothies, wraps and flatbreads. One bite of their new Tropic Bowls and you'll instantly feel like you're relaxing at a resort. The new Tropic Bowls are all made to order
Tropical Smoothie Cafe坚信你每天都应该享受一次度假，而不只是每年一次。他们推出了四款全新的热带碗，加入他们美味的热带冰沙、卷饼和薄饼系列。咬上一口他们的新款热带碗，你就会瞬间觉得自己正身处度假村放松。新款热带碗全部都是现点现做
topped with refreshing fruit, granola, chia seeds, and a delicious honey drizzle. Now that's what I call five star luxury by the spoonful. I can't wait to try these tropical smoothie bowls. I'm gonna get the new one, the mixed berry Greek yogurt. Oh my God, it sounds so good. It has everything I love. Greek yogurt, strawberries, blueberries, granola,
上面铺着清爽的水果、格兰诺拉麦片、奇亚籽和美味的蜂蜜细雨。这才是真正的勺勺五星级奢华享受。我迫不及待地想尝尝这些热带冰沙碗了。我要点那个新款的混合浆果希腊酸奶。天哪，听起来太棒了。它包含了我喜欢的一切。希腊酸奶、草莓、蓝莓、格兰诺拉麦片、
almonds, chia seeds, honey. I mean, it's just like, it sounds amazing. I can't wait. You're on Tropic Time now. Enjoy Sunshine by the Spoonfo with the new Tropic bowls at your local Tropical Smoothie Cafe. This episode of SmartLess is brought to you in part by Skinny Pop Popcorn. Hey guys, looking for some excitement in 2024?
杏仁、奇亚籽、蜂蜜。我的意思是，这听起来太棒了。我等不及了。你现在正处于热带时间。去你当地的Tropical Smoothie Cafe，用新款热带碗品尝勺勺阳光吧。本期SmartLess节目部分内容由Skinny Pop爆米花赞助播出。嘿，伙计们，在2024年寻找一些刺激吗？
Check out Skinny Pop's new Cheddar Jalapeno Popcorn, made with real cheddar cheese and a pop of jalapeno. This new flavor is sure to spice up your daily snacking routine. So Scott and I started this thing called Movies That Rule. It's a movie night, we have some friends over, and he created this whole trailer thing with like on his computer, I don't know how he did it, and it's this trailer of like all these upcoming movies, and then we watched this great like classic movie, and we were like, well, what do we got
来看看Skinny Pop全新的切达墨西哥辣椒味爆米花，采用真正的切达干酪和少许墨西哥辣椒制成。这种新口味一定会为你的日常零食时间增添一些风味。所以斯科特和我开始搞了一个叫做“统治电影”的活动。这是一个电影之夜，我们邀请一些朋友过来，他在电脑上制作了整个预告片，我不知道他是怎么做到的，这是所有这些即将上映的电影的预告片，然后我们看了一部非常棒的经典电影，我们当时就在想，好吧，我们有什么
for the people that come over? Well, we're gonna get Skinny Pop. We got, we really truly got Skinny Pop. We put bowls and bowls of it out. It just made Movies That Rule night even that much better. A deliciously simple combination of popcorn, oil, and salt, every bite of their perfectly popped original popcorn leaves you wanting more.
给来做客的人准备的？好吧，我们要准备Skinny Pop。我们准备了，我们真的准备了Skinny Pop。我们拿出了满满好几碗。这让“统治电影”之夜变得更加美妙。爆米花、油和盐的美味简单组合，每一口他们完美爆开的原味爆米花都让你回味无穷。
Skinny Pop is light and tasty and perfect for any occasion, whether you're on the go, staving off boredom, or unwinding after a long day. In addition to the original popcorn, Skinny Pop offers a variety of delicious flavors ranging from white cheddar to sweet and salty kettle. And I'm telling you, just by the title alone, the Cheddar Jalapeño Popcorn, I can't wait to try it.
Skinny Pop轻盈美味，适合任何场合，无论你是在路上、摆脱无聊，还是在漫长的一天后放松身心。除了原味爆米花，Skinny Pop还提供各种美味口味，从白切达干酪到香甜咸味焦糖爆米花应有尽有。我跟你说，光听名字，切达墨西哥辣椒味爆米花，我就迫不及待地想尝尝了。
Shop skinny pop now. Thanks to Zip Recruiter for their support. So my mornings are pretty routine. They're pretty relaxed. I get up a little extra early just so I can have a relaxing routine. I feed the dog, I lazily throw the toys in the backyard for him just to get his energy up.
现在就去买Skinny Pop吧。感谢Zip Recruiter的支持。所以我的早晨通常很有规律。它们相当轻松。我起得稍微早一点，只是为了能有一个轻松的规律。我喂狗，懒洋洋地把玩具扔到后院让他去捡，好让他消耗点精力。
And I kind of like just have like a really easy, lazy breakfast. Everybody loves downtime. It's nice to have downtime, but not all of our listeners are so lucky. So if you're a business owner or a hiring manager, you likely work around the clock. How can you get help?
我只想吃一顿非常轻松、闲适的早餐。每个人都喜欢闲暇时间。有闲暇时间很好，但并非我们所有的听众都那么幸运。所以，如果你是企业主或招聘经理，你很可能日夜操劳。你如何才能获得帮助？
At least help finding people with the right skills for your open roles? Zip Recruiter. And right now, you can try it for free at ziprecruiter.com slash smartlist. Zip Recruiter's powerful matching technology finds qualified candidates for you, then sends them to you. If you see a candidate you really like,
至少在为你的空缺职位寻找合适技能的人才方面获得帮助？Zip Recruiter。现在，你可以在ziprecruiter.com slash smartlist上免费试用它。Zip Recruiter强大的匹配技术为你寻找合格的候选人，然后将他们发送给你。如果你看到一个非常喜欢的候选人，
Zip Recruiter makes it easy to send them a personal invite to apply, to encourage them to apply sooner. In fact, over 3.8 million businesses have come to ZipRecruiter for their hiring needs. So take a break from hiring and let ZipRecruiter help. Four out of five employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate within the first day. See for yourself, go to this exclusive web address to try ZipRecruiter for free, ZipRecruiter.com slash SmartList. Again, that's ZipRecruiter.com slash S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S-S ZipRecruiter for free, ziprecruiter.com slash smartlist. Again, that's
Zip Recruiter让你可以轻松地向他们发送个人邀请函，鼓励他们更快地申请。事实上，已有超过380万家企业来到ZipRecruiter满足他们的招聘需求。所以，从招聘中休息一下，让ZipRecruiter来帮忙。在ZipRecruiter上发布招聘信息的雇主中，五分之四的人在第一天内就能获得优质候选人。亲自去体验一下吧，访问这个独家网址免费试用ZipRecruiter：ZipRecruiter.com slash SmartList。再说一遍，那是ZipRecruiter.com slash S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S-S，免费使用ZipRecruiter，网址是ziprecruiter.com slash smartlist。再说一遍，那是
ziprecruiter.com slash S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S-S ZipRecruiter, the smartest way to hire. And now, back to the show. Now, wait, now, Ronnie, how crazy do you get with your set? You put like, cause I see some guys they'll put like a big fucking gong back there sometimes and they'll put some kettle drums and they'll put like some of the xylophone that's hanging from like Christmas ornaments. Yeah, those things.
ziprecruiter.com slash S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S-S。ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。现在，让我们回到节目中。等等，罗尼，你的乐队配置有多疯狂？你是不是会放，因为我看到有些家伙有时会在后面放一个巨大的该死的大锣，他们会放一些定音鼓，还会放一些像从圣诞饰品上挂下来的木琴。对，就是那些东西。
And like, you get like real, real robust with your setup back there. Do you keep it simple? We were doing like a video, I have a gong, but we were doing this video where we were basically trying to do the Pink Floyd ripoff when they're in the Pompey video. And Nick Mason's got this awesome drum set with the gong.
就像，你在后面的配置搞得非常，非常扎实。你保持简单吗？我们当时在拍一个视频，我有一个大锣，但我们在拍这个视频时，基本上是想山寨平克·弗洛伊德在庞贝古城视频里的情景。尼克·梅森有一个很棒的鼓组，配有大锣。
It just looks great in the desert. We were making this video for human in the desert. Love that. But you guys made awesome videos, by the way, just as an aside. Thanks. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, it's true. And so it sort of started out with that.
它在沙漠里看起来太棒了。我们在沙漠里为human拍了这个视频。太棒了。顺便说一句，你们拍的视频真的很棒。谢谢。对，对，对，对，确实如此。所以它差不多就是从那个开始的。
And then I brought it on stage as almost a joke or like a backdrop and everything. And now I actually, I use it. You have like one of those big funny mallets. Yeah, big ass, you know, mallet size of a baby's head. And apart from that, I don't go too crazy. No, you guys wanna, yeah. No chime wipes. Brandon, what were you gonna say?
然后我把它带上舞台，几乎是当作一个笑话或者背景什么的。现在我真的在用了。你有一个那种大号的滑稽木槌吗？对，大得像婴儿脑袋一样的槌子。除此之外，我不会弄得太疯狂。不，你们想，对。没有风铃。布兰登，你刚才想说什么？
Oh, I was gonna bring some tenderness. Yeah. Some tenderness to this interview. You know that, do you remember you emailed me about Dustland, Will? You might not remember this, but I think this is how we first talked, is that I got an, you reached out about a song of ours
哦，我本想带点温柔。对。给这次采访带来一些温柔。你知道吗，你还记得你给我发过关于《Dustland》的邮件吗，威尔？你可能不记得了，但我认为这就是我们最初交流的方式，我收到了一封
called The Dustland Fairy Tale. Yes. And that was where we first, I think, connected. I think you're right. And those moments are few and far between where somebody will actually take the time to do that. And I appreciate it still. Yeah, I do remember that, man.
你关于我们的一首名为《The Dustland Fairy Tale》的歌的邮件。是的。我想这就是我们最初建立联系的地方。我想你是对的。这样的时刻少之又少，有人会真正花时间去做这件事。我至今仍然很感激。是的，我确实记得，老兄。
Yeah, listen, I love music and I've always been a fan of you guys and I find you guys, it's funny you're talking about, it's kind of circling back to talking about getting into sort of electronic music, et cetera, what I've always loved about you guys that I've thought a lot of your music is very anthemic. You know, like there's always like a big feel to it.
对，听着，我喜欢音乐，我一直是你们的粉丝，我觉得你们，有趣的是我们在谈论，这有点绕回到了开始讨论接触电子音乐等内容，我一直喜欢你们的地方在于，我认为你们的音乐很多都非常有赞美诗般的宏大感。你知道，就像它总有一种宏大的气势。
You guys are kind of big feel guys. And I love your lyrics and I love the way everything kind of builds in the same way. I love the lyrics build in a way. And sometimes I don't even know a lot of the time. I mean, I don't know what you're writing about is very personal probably and you don't explain it but there's just something about it.
你们算是一群注重宏大氛围的人。我喜欢你们的歌词，我喜欢一切以同样方式积蓄力量的方式。我喜欢歌词积蓄力量的方式。有时甚至很多时候我甚至都不知道。我的意思是，我不知道你写的东西可能非常私人，你也没有解释它，但它就是有某种特别之处。
And your music is the kind of music for me that evokes a lot of emotion. And- Will, are you crying right now? I'm always crying. I'm always crying, just know that. Yeah, it's okay. And I do remember reaching out to you
对我和我而言，你们的音乐是那种能唤起很多情感的音乐。而且——威尔，你现在在哭吗？我一直在哭。我一直在哭，你们要知道这一点。好吧，没关系。我确实记得联系过你
and of course when we emailed, we emailed a couple of times and I just, I don't know man, I just really appreciate it. I just love what you guys do and I find it very inspiring. I get really inspired by music because I can't play music. Uh-oh. Uh-oh. Oh, this is one of my tunes. This is one of my tunes.
当然当我们发邮件时，我们发了好几次邮件，我只是，我不知道老兄，我真的很感激。我只是喜欢你们所做的事情，我发现这非常鼓舞人心。音乐真的能给我很多启发，因为我不会玩音乐。噢哦。噢哦。哦，这是我的曲子之一。这是我的曲子之一。
Here's the neck pops. Here we go. This is your band? Here we go. I have one of my songs. Somebody take me. And someone says that. Look at the way he pops the net. Someone's angry, someone's sad. That sure stopped my tears. It's so bad.
听听这转脖子的声音。我们开始吧。这是你的乐队吗？来吧。我有一首自己的歌。带我走吧。有人这么说。看看他扭脖子的样子。有人生气，有人伤心。这倒真让我止住了眼泪。太糟糕了。
Okay, that's good. Oh, you're totally, is that you singing or no? Yeah, that's me singing. You're doing Andy Bell, you're doing Andy Bell. Total Andy Bell. A thousand percent. Andy Bell sings his ass off. That's unbelievable.
好吧，这很好。哦，你完全，那是你在唱歌吗？是的，那是我的你在模仿安迪·贝尔，你在模仿安迪·贝尔。完全是安迪·贝尔。百分之一千。安迪·贝尔唱得太拼了。这太不可思议了。
It's, he's sort of underrated in the, For tracing Andy Bell as the lead singer of Erasure. Man. Yeah, that was, I was like 1920, I don't know how that went. Here, hey, Brandon. That sounded good. I just found the email. You ready for this? What's the time stamp on? Is it like about 3, 3.40 in the morning? August. Hey, Brandon. That sounded good. I just found the email. You ready for this?
他，作为Erasure的主唱，安迪·贝尔有点被低估了。天哪。是的，那是，我当时大概19、20岁，我不知道当时是怎么回事。嘿，布兰登。听起来不错。我刚刚找到那封邮件。准备好听这个了吗？时间戳是什么时候？大概是早上3点、3点40分左右吗？八月。嘿，布兰登。听起来不错。我刚才找到那封邮件了。准备好听这个了吗？
What's the time stamp on? Is it like about 3.40 in the morning? August 5th, 2009. Does it start with you up? Hey man, you up. You up. No, it says, hey man, just want to drop you on set. I love Dazzline fairy tale.
时间戳是什么时候？是早上3点40左右吗？2009年8月5日。是不是以“你在吗”开头？嘿，伙计，你在吗。你在吗。不，上面写着，嘿，伙计，只想给你发个小样。我爱《Dazzline fairy tale》。
I can't stop listening to it, hypnotic. And then a dick pic. Anyway, going to sleep now. Fuck off. fairy tale. I can't stop listening to it hypnotic. And then a dick pic. Anyway, go on to sleep now. Call me, I'm putting my phone on DIY disturb. God is taking me back. Taking me back, right? So hang on, so just a couple more things.
我听个不停，太催眠了。然后是一张丁丁照。不管怎样，要睡觉了。滚开。童话。我听得停不下来，太催眠了。然后是一张丁丁照。不管怎样，要去睡觉了。给我打电话，我把手机调成免打扰了。上帝带我回去了。带我回去了，对吧？所以等等，还有几件事。
So when you do get together, you guys feel it, you've got the right energy, you've got the right energy, you've got the right kind of a balance, or like you feel like you guys are kind of playing off each other and you're all working towards the same place or the same vibe. And then you start to record your first record. And, you know, look, doing that,
所以当你们聚在一起时，你们会有这种感觉，你们有正确的能量，你们有正确的能量，你们有那种平衡感，或者你们觉得你们在互相配合，你们都在朝着同一个目标或同样的氛围努力。然后你们开始录制第一张专辑。而且，你知道，听着，做这件事，
anytime we do anything, and guys, we do it as well, all of us, when you're working on something new, you're doing it in a vacuum. And other than the people who you kind of work with, you have no sense as to whether or not people are gonna like it. You're like, people might hate this. They might say, this is, and so what was that feeling
任何时候我们做任何事，伙计们，我们也是这样，我们所有人，当你在创作新东西时，你都是在真空中进行的。除了和你一起工作的人之外，你完全不知道别人是否会喜欢它。你会想，人们可能会讨厌这个。他们可能会说，这太……所以当时那种感觉是怎样的
on the first record before people knew who the killers were? It's just, it all sort of just started to roll. We had garage recordings that were just us playing in my garage with two microphones and a CD recorder. And we got to the point where we were everybody's amps and the drums and everything sounded like it was being mixed, but it was just a room recording. We do demos and things like that.
在人们知道杀手乐队是谁之前的那第一张专辑？这一切就像是自然而然地滚动起来了。我们的车库录音只是我们在我的车库里用两个麦克风和一个CD录音机录制的。我们当时达到了那种程度，所有人的功放、鼓和所有听起来都像是被混音过，但其实只是一个房间录音。我们做小样和类似的东西。
We didn't have any proper recordings and there was this guy who put us in touch with a fella who had a studio in Northern California. We need to get you guys a proper recording. And we just went in there for, we did one or two takes of each song. You guys paid for the studio time yourself? Or he gave it? We did a spec deal with this guy.
我们没有任何正式的录音，有个家伙把我们介绍给了一个在北加州有录音室的人。我们需要给你们做一个正式的录音。我们就在那里呆了，每首歌我们只录了一到两次。你们自己出钱租的录音室吗？还是他提供的？我们跟这个人签了一个投机协议。
He says, I'm gonna, I'll record this for free. I'm gonna have Mark Needham, who's a famous mix engineer. He's done Chris Isaac and, you know, Fleetwood Mac and countless others. And he'll mix it, but we want a year to shop it if we do this. We're like, shit, it's a free record.
他说，我来，我免费录音。我会请马克·尼德姆，一个著名的混音工程师。他给克里斯·艾萨克、弗利特伍德·迈克以及无数其他人做过。他来混音，但如果我们这样做，我们需要一年的推销期。我们心想，操，这是一张免费的唱片。
Okay, let's do it. And they like put us up in like budget suites in Berkeley, California. And we made the, and that was the first record is all those demos. They were just like, okay, well, this'll work for the first. It started out as being an EP. And then we, with this little deal, a little small indie label
好吧，我们干吧。他们把我们安排在加州伯克利像经济型套房一样的地方。我们制作了，第一张专辑就是所有这些小样。他们当时只是觉得，好吧，这作为第一张专辑可行。它一开始是一张EP。然后我们通过这笔小交易，一家小型独立厂牌
in England called Lizard King. It was the first time I had Thai food in Berkeley. Really? Yeah. Sean wants to know if you've ever tried Chin Chin. Yeah, we do the Chin Chin. Plus relative. Sean, wait, this is great.
在英国，叫做Lizard King。那是我在伯克利第一次吃泰国菜。真的吗？是的。肖恩想知道你有没有试过金琴。对，我们去过金琴。加上亲戚。肖恩，等等，这太棒了。
Sean, do you enjoy Thai food? I love Thai food, yeah. Yeah. I love the different sauces. You know, in Vegas, we have a place, Lotus of Siam, if you guys ever go to Vegas. Lotus of Siam. And it's the, I mean, you got Night Market Song
肖恩，你喜欢泰国菜吗？我喜欢泰国菜，是的。是的。我喜欢各种酱汁。你知道，在维加斯，我们有个地方，暹罗莲花，如果你们去维加斯的话。暹罗莲花。而且它是，我的意思是，你们有夜市歌曲
is amazing in LA, but it's Vegas has this one. It's called Lotus of Siam, and it's not on the strip, it's off the strip, but it is the greatest. I'll tell you what you need to try next time you're in Vegas is the sphere. Once you guys go play the sphere, that place is incredible. Oh, did you already go?
在洛杉矶很棒，但维加斯有这一家。它叫暹罗莲花，不在大道上，在稍微偏一点的地方，但它是最棒的。我跟你讲你下次去维加斯得试试那个球体剧场。等你们去那个球体剧场演出，那个地方太不可思议了。哦，你们已经去过了吗？
Yeah, I went to that U2 show. It's unbelievable that venue. Man, it looks just the pictures, your mouth is... What do you guys think of Vegas? Like, live in there? You don't live there, Ronnie, Brandon, you do, right? I moved away too. Oh, you did?
对，我去看过U2的那个演出。那个场馆太不可思议了。天哪，光看照片，你嘴巴都合不拢……你们觉得维加斯怎么样？就像，住在那里？你们不住在那儿吧，罗尼，布兰登，你们住在那儿，对吧？我也搬走了。哦，是吗？
Yeah, so three of us were born there. You ever run into Kimmel? You ever see Kimmel over there when you're in Vegas? Ronnie went to the same high school as Jimmy. Really? Jimmy's a lot older. A lot. He's a lot.
对，所以我们三个是在那儿出生的。你们遇到过吉梅尔吗？你在维加斯的时候见过吉梅尔吗？罗尼和吉米上的是同一所高中。真的吗？吉米大很多。大得多。他大得……
Full stop. He's a lot older. No, I think that was the end of his sentence. Jimmy's a lot. And he is a lot. He's a lot older. No, I think that was the end of his sentence. Jimmy's a lot. And he is a lot. He is a lot. We can say this officially, Kimmel is a lot. So you went to the same, but it's a good question.
句号。他大得多。不，我想那是他这句话的结束。吉米很大。而且他确实很大。他大得多。不，我想那是他这句话的结束。吉米很大。而且他确实很大。他真的很大。我们可以正式宣布这一点，吉米真的很大。所以你们去了同一个，但这是个好问题。
Like being from Vegas, like what Sean was asking, like I always think that, I've actually asked this to Kimmel too. Like is it a weird place to be from? It wasn't until we left. Yeah. And you know. That's a great answer.
就像来自维加斯一样，就像肖恩刚才问的，我总是觉得，我其实也问过吉梅尔这个问题。作为一个从那里出来的人，那是个奇怪的地方吗？直到我们离开后才觉得。对。而且你知道。那是个绝佳的回答。
You realize how weird it is. Yeah, and so you're just accustomed to seeing ads first, you know, billboards for strip clubs and there are slot machines when you go to 7-Eleven. Like that's just, there's my grandma's gonna be playing slots while I'm getting my slurpee. Like that's what life is like. Wow. And that's, and you don't realize that that's foreign to other people.
你才意识到它是多么奇怪。是的，所以你习惯了一开始就看到广告，你知道，脱衣舞俱乐部的广告牌，当你去7-Eleven时还有老虎机。就像那样，当我买思乐冰时，我奶奶会在旁边玩老虎机。生活就是这样的。哇。而且，你并没有意识到这对其他人来说是多么陌生。
How did you end up in Northern California for the record? Did you, were you guys, did you guys all kind of relocate there? Oh, that's just where Saltzman studio was. No, oh, so that was, Oh, gotcha. Yeah, that's just where thezman studio is. No, oh, so that was, Oh, gotcha. Yeah, that's just where the studio, this guy just was high on building his brand new studio
你们是怎么落脚在北加州录制这张专辑的？你们是，你们所有人算是一起搬到那里去了吗？哦，索尔兹曼的录音室就在那儿。不，哦，所以那是，哦，明白了。对，索尔兹曼的录音室就在那儿。不，哦，所以那是，哦，明白了。对，录音室就在那儿，这家伙当时正热衷于建立他全新的录音室
and it was very eager to record someone. Gotcha. So you guys are relocated out of Vegas into where are you now? We're all over the place. I'm in Texas right now. I live in Utah. Oh, all right. Okay, I live in Utah for a while.
而且非常渴望能录制点什么。明白了。所以你们从维加斯搬出来了，现在你们在哪里？我们到处都是。我现在在得克萨斯州。我住在犹他州。哦，好吧。好吧，我在犹他州住过一段时间。
I live in Utah for a while. I have a question. When you guys, after a show is done and you play the show, do you guys have like, and you're feeling that adrenaline still, do you have like a routine or some kind of something you do to come down? Like do you go out? You're like, you know what, I'm done, I'm spent,
我在犹他州住过一段时间。我有个问题。当你们，演出结束之后，演完一场演出，你们会有那种，而且肾上腺素还在飙升的时候，你们有什么例行公事或者某种用来放松的方法吗？比如你们会出去吗？你会觉得，你知道吗，我结束了，我累垮了，
I'm gonna go right to bed. Or are you still high on the energy? I devour food. You do? Do you not eat before the show? About four, I get four hours before the gig. Yeah. You don't want anything in your stomach
我要直接去睡觉。还是你们的亢奋状态依然持续？我狂吃食物。真的吗？你演出前不吃东西吗？演出前大概四个小时，我拿四个小时。是的。你可不想肚子里有什么东西
for four hours before the gig because it might get a little growly. Yeah, you just feel heavy. You feel, you know, I don't want to feel full and I don't, and the acid reflux, all that kind of stuff. If it hits your cords, yeah. Yeah, yeah, Jason. Yeah. Well, when you say cords, you're your chords. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Jason? Yeah.
在演出前四个小时吃，因为可能会有点咕咕叫。对，你只是觉得沉重。你觉得，你知道的，我不想觉得饱，而且胃酸倒流，诸如此类的事情。如果刺激到声带，对。是的，是的，杰森。对。好吧，当你提到声带时，你指的是裤子。声带。哦，是的。天哪。你说你住在犹他州？我确实住过。从我四岁到七岁，我们住在盐湖城。为此我非常高兴。
Well, when you say chords, you're talking about the pants. The vocal chords. Oh, yes. Jesus. Did you say you lived in Utah? I did. From when I was four till I was seven, we lived in Salt Lake.
好吧，当你提到声带时，你指的是裤子。声带。哦，是的。天哪。你说你住在犹他州？我确实住过。从我四岁到七岁，我们住在盐湖城。
I forget why my parents were there, but learned how to ski. Yeah. Snowbird and Alta. Wonderful, so it wasn't late. Yeah, no, no, no, not at all, beautiful state. When I was a kid, I swear I, one of my first celebrity sightings was you. Come on, maybe I was there skiing
我不记得我爸妈当时为什么去那儿了，不过我学会了滑雪。对。Snowbird和Alta。太好了，所以不算太晚。对，不不不，完全不算，很棒的州。我小时候，我发誓，我见到的第一个名人就是你。得了吧，也许是我在那儿滑雪时……
when I was a little bit older. No, no, no, it wasn't in YouTube, it was like in Reno or Wendover. I can't remember, but it was in between. It had been Reno. And we were checking into some place because there was like a Reno or Wendover. I can't remember, but it was in between. It had been Reno. And we were checking into some place because there was like a storm or something, and we had to, and I remember being like,
我再稍微大一点的时候。不，不，不，不是在YouTube上，而是在雷诺（Reno）或者温多弗（Wendover）。我记不清了，但就在两地之间。应该是雷诺。我们在某个地方登记入住，因为当时有暴风雨什么的，我们不得不……我记得当时……
I was only eight or nine, but I- So Jason was 25. You were famous. Well, I barely, that's a kind word. By the way, Brendan's got a very good memory, so let's keep going with this. And I was, anyway, I was excited because I was like, that's him and trying to, and my mom wasn't sure.
我才八九岁，但我——所以当时杰森25岁。你当时已经很有名了。好吧，我勉强算吧，你这词用得真委婉。顺便说一句，布兰登记性很好，所以咱们继续聊这个。当时，不管怎样，我很兴奋，因为我想，那就是他，然后还试图……我妈当时还不确定。
Was it 8 AM? Was it 8 AM? And it looked like he'd been up. Yeah. Was I coming? Was I looking dejected from a blackjack table at the pepper mill? You?
那是早上8点吗？那是早上8点吗？看起来他好像刚熬过夜。对。我是不是正朝……我是不是带着一副从胡椒磨坊赌场（Pepper Mill）的21点桌旁铩羽而归的沮丧表情？我？
That was me. Was the exchanging cash for the dude behind the 7-Eleven? You were like, you were with, you had some friends with you, but you were like running the, you were running the show, I remember. Yeah, I thought I was pretty, pretty hot shit. Did he have a, did he have a motor home
那是我。是不是在7-Eleven便利店后面跟那家伙换现金？你当时……你跟一些朋友在一起，但你就像是主事的，我记得。对，我当时觉得自己牛得不行。他当时是不是有一辆……
with some dirt bikes on it? Was he with Leif Garrett? Yeah, Leif Garrett, all the way north. He might have been with Leif Garrett. By the way, you know what's funny? So you guys are from Vegas and then you moved all over the States and you've kind of lived everywhere. But, but you got, I, my, my impression is that you guys are from Vegas and then you moved all over the States and you've kind of lived everywhere but but you got I my my impression is that you guys really
带着几辆越野摩托车的房车？他是跟雷夫·加勒特（Leif Garrett）在一起吗？对，雷夫·加勒特，一路向北。他可能是跟雷夫·加勒特在一起。话说回来，你知道意思吗？你们是Vegas（拉斯维加斯）人，后来搬到了全美各地，基本上哪儿都住过。但是，但是你们……我……我的印象是，你们是Vegas人，后来搬到了全美各地，基本上哪儿都住过，但是，但是你们……我……我的印象是，你们真的……
You're so huge in the UK. I talked about it before you guys kind of in a way Am I right didn't you guys kind of broke through first in the UK? Yeah Yeah, so that first record we recorded in in Berkeley Was then put out by this small indie label. And that's what became our first record, Hot Fuss. And... Yeah. Well, all the major American labels said no.
你们在英国超级火。我之前说过，在某种程度上，你们……我说的对吗？你们是不是最先在英国崭露头角的？对。对，所以我们录制的首张专辑在伯克利（Berkeley），然后被一家小型独立唱片公司发行了。这就成了我们的第一张专辑《Hot Fuss》。而且……对。好吧，所有美国主流唱片公司都拒绝了。
Every... So we went with this small label in England. Who believed in us. Wow. Well, like these guys believe in us. So we went over there and... Go to the love. I think we did like four or five shows
每家……所以我们去了英国的那家小公司。他们相信我们。哇。就像这些家伙相信我们一样。所以我们就去了那边……去感受那种爱。我想我们大概做了四五场演出……
and the enemy was covering it. And it was just like things were starting to sort of bloom a little bit. And we got home two or three weeks later and all the American labels were taking us out to dinner. We ate really well for a few months. We were just broke. We all still had jobs.
《新音乐快递》（NME）还报道了。事情就像是开始有点起色了。两三周后我们回到家，所有美国的唱片公司都请我们出去吃饭。有好几个月我们吃得非常好。我们当时只是身无分文。我们大家当时都还有工作。
I was, you know, Brandon was at the Gold Coast slinging bags and I was taking pictures at a wedding chapel on the strip and Dave was like. No way, no way. Yeah, that was my last job. And so everything was started to, everything was starting to sort of come down a little bit. Every show we'd play, there'd be somebody
我当时……你知道的，布兰登在黄金海岸赌场（Gold Coast）搬行李，我在大道上的一个婚礼教堂拍照片，而戴夫他……不可能，绝对不可能。对，那是我的最后一份工作。所以一切都开始……一切都开始有点眉目了。我们演出的每一场，都会有……
from some record label. Ronnie, how was your, as a photographer there, how was your chat to your subjects when you were shooting and they were really getting good shots and stuff? Would you ever say stuff like dynamite, dynamite, like, what was your go-to chat? And that stuff. Right to me, right to me.
来自某家唱片公司的人。罗尼，你在那儿当摄影师的时候，拍照时是怎么跟拍摄对象聊天的？当他们拍出很棒的照片之类的时候，你会说像“太棒了，太棒了”这样的话吗？你的惯用台词是什么？诸如此类的话。看着我，看着我。
Now over here, I'm not even here. I'm not even here. You're looking more leg. More leg. Yeah, dynamite leg. Wait, you're a photographer. You're not gonna regret this. You're not gonna regret this.
现在看这边，我甚至不在这儿。我甚至不在这儿。你得展现更多腿部线条。更多腿。对，火辣的腿。等等，你是个摄影师。你不会后悔的。你不会后悔的。
Right, that's a good one. Right, who's that? Who's that over there? Who regret this. Right, that's a good one. Right, who's that? Who's that over there? Who's that over there? It was a good job. It was a good job. Brandon, what were you doing?
对，这句不错。对，那是谁？那边那是谁？你会后悔的。对，这句不错。对，那是谁？那边那是谁？那边是谁？那是一份不错的工作。那是一份不错的工作。布兰登，你当时在干什么？
You were slinging back? I was a bellman. Yeah, I was a bellman at the Gold Coast. Oh, at the Gold Coast. I do wanna talk about this as its own little session because I know that we might, you know, we may or may not be able to use this or whatever, but you guys are potentially, maybe I've heard,
你在搬行李？我是个门童。对，我在黄金海岸赌场当门童。哦，在黄金海岸赌场。我真的很想把这个当作一个独立的小环节来聊，因为我知道我们可能会——或者可能不会——把这个用在节目里什么的，不过你们可能，也许我听说……
gonna speaking of Vegas, do a residency. Is that true? It's true. Oh, I'm going. This is, we'll give you tickets. Wait. No, of course you will. Of course. Don't say, of course. Sean's in the band. He's going to be there. I'm going to hold up a sign instead of the instead of the drummer Instead of Ronnie you I'm gonna just play my keyboard right now Bono Bono kind of gently mentioned his residency there at the at the sphere before it all happened Yeah, it's it's it's gonna be a cold coast it's gonna be at the yeah the Coliseum
说到拉斯维加斯，你们要在那里驻唱。是真的吗？是真的。哦，我要去。这个嘛，我们会给你票。等等。不，你当然会。当然。别说“当然”。肖恩也在乐队里。他会去的。我要举个牌子，不当鼓手了……我不当罗尼了，我这就去弹我的键盘。博诺（Bono）之前在那个……在那个蜂巢球体场（Sphere）演出前，有点含蓄地提过他在那儿的驻唱活动。对，它……它将会在……黄金海岸……它将会去……对，那个体育馆……
Oh for real and Caesar's Palace. I saw Celine Dion there. Yeah. Yeah, and so It's you know, we're really excited. It's 20. It's gonna be 20 years since our first record So we're gonna play the album front to back and And then we'll then we'll leave and come back and play you know eight or nine more singles or whatever like, you know, whatever That's really cool. When does that start August is the potential? It's the last couple weeks of August. Yeah, something like that Is so exciting 2024. Yeah, no no no August of 23 you ding dong They built a time machine just What do you- Hop aboard.
哦，真的吗？在凯撒宫（Caesars Palace）。我在那儿看过席琳·迪翁（Celine Dion）的演出。对。对，所以……你知道的，我们真的很兴奋。距离我们的第一张专辑发行已经20年了。所以我们要从头到尾完整演奏这张专辑，然后……然后我们离开，再回来演奏八九首单曲什么的，你知道的，随便什么都行……这真的很酷。什么时候开始？潜在的时间是八月？是八月的最后几周。对，差不多那样。太令人兴奋了，2024年。不不不，是23年8月，你个大笨蛋。他们造了一台时光机，就……你想不想……跳上船吧。
I'll totally go to that. This guy was nominated for best host of the year. You guys, that's so awesome. How- I just- again, I just want to follow up with this. How it is, you know, it's been 20 years and now you're going to do this residency in your hometown. It's got to feel kind of great. It's really cool. Ronnie's mom worked at Caesars Palace for 40 years.
我绝对会去那儿。这家伙被提名为了年度最佳主持人。你们这些家伙，这太棒了。怎么……我只是——再次重申，我只想跟进问一下。这种感觉如何，你知道的，已经过去20年了，现在你们要在自己的家乡驻唱。感觉一定很棒吧。真的很酷。罗尼的妈妈在凯撒宫工作了40年。
Oh wow. What? Wow. And I used to go, I worked at Spago as a bus boy inside Caesars Palace. And it was where I bought, they used to have a virgin records there. And I took every bit of money that I had
哦，哇。什么？哇。我以前常去，我在凯撒宫里面的Spago餐厅当过杂工。那里的……他们以前在那儿有一家维珍唱片店（Virgin Records）。我把我所有的钱……
and spent it at Virgin Records. It's so cool to come back. When we were kids, there was a thing called the OmniMax, those dome theaters. Yeah, yeah, OmniMax. And that's the original sphere. Yeah, they tore it down, and that's where the Colosseum is built.
全都花在维珍唱片店了。回来感觉太棒了。我们小时候，有个叫俄勒麦克斯（OmniMax）的东西，就是那些球幕影院。对，对，俄勒麦克斯。那就是最初的“球体场（Sphere）”。对，他们把它拆了，凯撒宫就是在那上面建起来的。
It just, it really feels like a special thing to go back there. Oh man, that's so awesome. Well, I'm so happy for you guys. I'm so happy for the audiences, for us, that we get to come and see you guys do that. See the way Will just got free tickets from you guys with that little comment right now.
真的，那种感觉就像是一件很特别的事，能回到那个地方。天哪，太棒了。好吧，我真为你们感到高兴。我真为观众们高兴，为我们高兴，能来看你们做这件事。你看威尔刚才就凭那句随口的话从你们这儿拿到免费门票了。
Well, I know. Brandon, you've still got the same email address, I'm hoping, right? Yeah. Okay, Brandon, I'm gonna hit you up. I'll email you later today. You guys just be cool, okay? Sean, high school, your nickname, Busboy, was that true?
好吧，我懂。布兰登，我希望你还是用原来那个电子邮箱地址，对吧？对。好吧，布兰登，我要联系你了。我今天晚些时候发邮件给你。你们几个稍微收敛点，好吗？肖恩，高中时的绰号是“杂工”，那是真的吗？
Okay. Guys, honestly, we have, once again, we've taken up, you guys just too much of your time. We could just, I could ask you guys about your music all day. I've just been such a fan, as you know, for a long time. You guys were just unbelievable talents. And thanks for taking the time during your tour. I know you guys are tired and you're in your hotel room.
好吧。伙计们，说实话，我们已经……再次占用你们太多时间了。我们本可以一整天都缠着你们问关于音乐的事。正如你们所知，我是你们多年的超级粉丝。你们有着令人难以置信的天赋。谢谢你们在巡演期间抽出时间。我知道你们很累，而且待在酒店房间里。
I know. Oh, it's so good. Yeah, I'm sure. We really, really appreciate it. This is a joy. And please, please, please send me your electronic album that you threw out just so I can enjoy it. I would actually love to hear it.
我知道。哦，太棒了。对，我敢肯定。我们真的、真的很感激。这太令人高兴了。而且，求求你们，请把你们扔掉的那张电子乐专辑发给我，好让我欣赏一下。其实我真的很想听听。
You will not upload it. I will not upload it to the internet. But what a pleasure. What an honor having you guys on this show. It's great to see you guys again. Like thank you guys. Nice to meet you guys. Very nice to meet you.
你不会把它上传的。我不会把它上传到互联网上的。但这真是一件乐事。能请你们上这个节目真是莫大的荣幸。很高兴再次见到你们。谢谢你们。很高兴认识你们。非常高兴认识你们。
Bye guys. Thank you guys so much. See you. See you later. Bye bye bye. Cheers. What a nice couple of gentlemen. Will, it's about time you found some nice friends.
再见，伙计们。非常感谢你们。回头见。回头见。拜拜拜。干杯。多好的一对绅士啊。威尔，你也该去交几个好朋友了。
They're good dudes, aren't they? They're good dudes. And yeah, I did look back. Canadian level of nice. They are Canadian level. Well, they have a lot of Canadian influence. And I will say, I was just looking back at the email. My email exchanges with Brandon over the years
他们人很好，对吧？他们人很好。而且，是的，我确实回顾了一下。加拿大级别的友善。他们确实是加拿大级别的。好吧，他们受了很多加拿大文化的影响。而且我得说，我刚才在翻看邮件。我和布兰登这些年来的邮件往来……
are very random, but I've always been such a huge fan. And it's true, like, you know, when you get just, I don't know, certain things that can inspire you or whatever and you feel like, I gotta let him know. Yeah, yeah. How great it is, what they do. And, you know, they, obviously they sell millions of records and millions of fans turn up at their shows,
非常天马行空，但我一直都是个超级大粉丝。真的，你知道的，当你遇到……我不知道，某些能够启发你的事情之类的，你会觉得，我得让他知道。对，对。他们的所作所为是多么伟大。而且，你知道的，显然他们卖出了数百万张唱片，数百万粉丝出现在他们的演会上……
but I don't know, I think it's nice to reach out to people and say, hey, you're really great. And what you did was really inspiring and awesome. And how lucky that he wasn't a jerk, right? It's like they'd be careful. You don't meet your heroes. Like how terrible would that have been if he was just like, yeah, great. So what? Goodbye.
但我不知道，我觉得主动联系别人说“嘿，你真的很棒，你做的事真的很有启发性而且太棒了”，这种感觉很好。而且幸运的是，他不是个混蛋，对吧？这就好比你要小心。千万别去见你的偶像。如果他只是说“哦，那又怎样？再见”，那该有多糟糕。
Yeah. Yeah. But the opposite happened. I like them. I feel like I've known them. Right? Yeah. Yeah. They should be called The Lovers early. I mean, did you guys like my other song?
对。对。但结果恰恰相反。我喜欢他们。我觉得我好像认识他们一样。对吧？对。对。他们应该一开始就叫“情人乐队（The Lovers）”。我是说，你们喜欢我的另一首歌吗？
You haven't heard that song yet. Boy, I think I'm losing you. Are you going over a canyon? Hello? Hello. Can you hear me? Sean? Yeah.
你们还没听过那首歌呢。天哪，我觉得信号要断了。你们是在峡谷里吗？喂？喂。听得到我说话吗？肖恩？对。
Will, when you got a second, we're just doing the wrap up. Yes, sorry. Sorry. So. Anyway, there's such nice dudes too. There's such nice normal for huge, no, I was going to say for huge mega stars. I was reading one of my annoying emails to Brandon, which is about whether my sister
威尔，等你有空的时候，我们就要收尾了。好，抱歉。抱歉。所以。总之，他们人也太好了。对于超级巨星来说，他们真是……不，我是说对于超级巨星来说。我当时在读我发给布兰登的一封烦人的邮件，内容是关于我妹妹……
could go say hi to them after the show. You talking about champagne wanted to go? It's Chardonnay. Sorry. Chardonnay wanted to them after the show. Oh, that's nice. You talking about Champagne wanted to go? It's Chardonnay, sorry. Chardonnay wanted to go. Shanley, Shanley. Shanley. I wanted to ask them like about the AI thing. Like your question about like the drum,
能不能在演出结束后去跟他们打个招呼。你说的是香槟想去？是霞多丽（Chardonnay），对不起。是霞多丽想去跟他们打个招呼。哦，那挺好。你说的是香槟想去？是霞多丽，对不起。霞多丽想去。香利（Shanley），香利。香利。我想问他们关于人工智能（AI）的事。比如你关于鼓的问题……
like can AI take over like right songs? Can I tell you something? Nobody's better at asking questions after the guest has gone than you, Sean. You are. We're gonna have another podcast called Follow Up. It's just gonna be you, Sean. Will and I are gonna skip that one.
比如AI能不能接管写歌？我能告诉你吗？在嘉宾离开后提问这件事，没有人比你更擅长了，肖恩。你真的是。我们要开办另一个播客节目叫《后续追踪》。里面就只有你，肖恩。威尔和我打算跳过那一期。
Hey, I'm talking to nobody. Hey, by the way, how do robots say goodbye? Bye. No, they use binary. Binary, baby. Don't tweak your nips when you say it. She's leaning back so satisfied. Bye. Smart.
嘿，我是在自言自语。嘿，顺便问一下，机器人是怎么说再见的？再见。不，它们用二进制。二进制，宝贝。说这话的时候别捏你的乳头。她靠向椅背，一脸满足。再见。聪明。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Floss. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjolf, Bennett Barbicow, and Michael Granteri. Smart. Floss. I A phone is ringing all night, wondering who somebody's at We're not feeling the torture alone Toucher of love If you like smart lists, you can listen early and add free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts. Prime members can listen ad free on Amazon Music.
无知。聪明。无知。聪明。牙线。SmartLess是由罗布·阿尔约尔夫（Rob Armjolf）、贝内特·巴尔比考（Bennett Barbicow）和迈克尔·格兰特里（Michael Granteri）100%有机纯手工打造。聪明。牙线。电话整晚响个不停，不知道谁在另一头 我们不愿独自感受折磨 爱之抚摸 如果你喜欢《SmartLess》，现在就可以通过加入Wondry App或苹果播客上的Wondry Plus，提前收听无广告版。Prime会员可以在亚马逊音乐上免广告收听。
Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at wendry.com slash survey. Many put their hope in Dr. Serhat. His company was worth half a billion dollars. His research promised groundbreaking treatments for HIV and cancer. Scientists, doctors, renowned experts were saying, genius, genius, genius. People that knew him were convinced that he saved their life. But the brilliant doctor was hiding a secret. Do not cross this line that was being messaged to us.
在离开之前，请花点时间在wendry.com/survey填写简短的问卷，告诉我们关于你的信息。许多人将希望寄托在瑟哈特（Serhat）医生身上。他的公司价值五亿美元。他的研究承诺为艾滋病和癌症提供开创性的治疗方法。科学家、医生、知名专家纷纷表示：“天才，天才，天才。”了解他的人都坚信他救了他们的命。但这位才华横溢的医生却隐藏着一个秘密。不要越过这条线，这是传达给我们的信息。
Do not cross this line. A secret the doctor was desperate to keep. This was a person who was willing to cold-heartedly just lie to people's faces. We're dealing with an international fugitive. From Wondery, the makers of Over My Dead Body and the Shrink Next Door comes a new season of Doctor Death. Bad magic. You can listen to Doctor Death Bad Magic, add free,
不要越过这条线。一个医生拼命想要保守的秘密。这是一个冷血地对人们面不改色撒谎的人。我们在和一个国际逃犯打交道。来自Wondry——《在我死后》（Over My Dead Body）和《隔壁的心理医生》（The Shrink Next Door）的制作团队，带来了新一季的《死亡医生》（Dr. Death）。邪恶魔力。你可以通过订阅Wondry App或苹果播客上的Wondry Plus，免广告收听《死亡医生：邪恶魔力》，
by subscribing to Wondery Plus in the Wondery app or on Apple podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。